Hello my friends.
It's time again,
this episode of the podcast,
um,
this July 4th weekend.
So,
uh,
I know you're going to be out
there at the lake or the beach,
taking your clothes off,
trying to look sexy and your swimsuit
and it's probably a disaster.
We can help you ladies.
Gentlemen,
this episode is brought to you
by [inaudible] Dot Com it's O.
N.
I.
T.
I've always been a big proponent of
kettlebells because it's one of the first
weightlifting things that I've ever done
that allows me to kind of get like the
whole workout in like a lot of times
when I used to lift weights regular,
I'd lift weights and then
another day I do cardio.
I do one day weights,
one day cardio,
but with a really good
kettle bell workout,
I get a brutal cardio workout and it
allows me to get it all done in one shot.
I'm a huge fan of them.
They just,
it's fun to do and it's a,
it makes you feel like some Russian
savage living in Siberia back in the 1930s
or whatever the fuck they invented.
These things,
what they are is it's like a cannon ball
with a big metal handle on it and you
swing them around.
And uh,
in,
in doing so and all
these various exercises,
you develop what they
call functional strength,
meaning strength for your entire body,
not isolated individual movements,
but your entire body.
And uh,
did they have no chimp?
Where's the Chin and
say something's missing?
The motherfuckers ran
out of chimps ran away.
Now we must have run out.
Those fucking things sell like crazy.
That's the primal bells.
The primal bells are these
new kettle bells that we had.
This is the most important thing.
They look cool as shit.
They're,
they're there.
We have chimpanzees and
then we also have zombies.
We have a apes rather.
We also have zombies.
But the,
um,
the most important things that
they don't just look good,
but that they're three d mapped.
What we have them is we
made sure that all of the,
a kettle bells that you're getting there,
they're not imbalanced.
You can make a cool face,
but if the cool face wasn't balanced,
it would kind of defeat the
purpose of the kettle bell.
The whole idea about a kettle bells,
it's gotta be balanced when you
move it so it looks bad ass,
but you get a,
like I use the uh,
the gorilla and you get a
really good workout with it.
It doesn't feel at all like a gimmick
even when it slams into your arm with
gorilla face first.
If you're an idiot,
if you're not paying attention
to how you swinging kettlebells,
one thing that I can,
um,
really not stress enough
when it comes to this stuff.
If you're thinking about doing
any kind of physical activity,
if you've never worked out before,
you've got to do two things.
If you can,
the one thing,
the,
if you can part is hire
a personal trainer.
Show you how to do the
movements correctly.
Just,
you know,
find out there's someone
will do it for you.
Probably let you iPhone video it and let,
let someone you know,
show you how to do like a clean and press,
how to do a windmill.
How to do these things
correctly and then videotape it.
And then you could do it on your own and
you could literally never have to go to
a gym again with a chin up bar
and a couple of kettle bells.
Like you can get ferocious
workouts and on a daily basis,
but start slow.
It's if you're a meathead
like me and in you're
a dummy and you,
if you know someone says,
uh,
take three vitamins you like hope said,
fuck it,
farm and see what's up,
you could hurt yourself with
these things start slow.
We have 35 pounders.
We have 18 pounders,
the howler monkeys,
18 pounds.
And uh,
we go all the way up to 70
pounds with the primal bells.
But if you're a real savage,
one of those bonafide fitness freaks,
like perhaps one of those cow,
those crossfit dudes who,
uh,
enter into those championships,
that bitch ass 70 pounds probably
not going to be enough for you.
If that's the case,
we sell him even heavier.
The heaviest ones we sell,
I don't know why they do them.
And kilograms,
I guess that's out of respect
to mother Russia or some shit.
They all say kilogram foods anymore.
Whatever that means.
Yeah,
we got rid of food,
but it's now it's still in kilogram.
Okay.
What the fuck is 40 kilograms?
Let's find out.
Let's tell people,
I think it's 88 pounds.
Let's see here that they would do that.
Yeah,
it seems odd for Americans.
What is 40 kilograms and power?
Yes,
it's 88 pounds.
So that's the heaviest one we have.
If you could throw around
in 88 pound Kettlebell,
you are some kind of man,
Huh?
Everybody else starts slow,
be healthy.
And like I said,
it's my favorite all time method
of just physical exercise.
Just,
you know,
without martial arts being
the obvious number one,
but just for regular exercise,
kettlebells are the
shit and it feels good.
It feels good when you do them.
It's just,
it's like a,
it's,
you're stretching out a lot
and a lot of the moment.
So it's got almost like a
yoga sort of a vibe to it.
Like windmills,
windmills,
or some of my favorite things to do with
super good for your core and your back
and,
but again,
do them slow.
And,
uh,
if you're interested in any of the audits,
supplements,
use the Codeword Rogan and you will
save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
Crash from the float lab is here,
Ladies and gentlemen.
So without any further ado
and no more fuckery of foot,
let's get rolling.
Well,
good experience.
[inaudible]
hey ladies and gentlemen,
for many of you who've
heard this podcast before,
you're aware of a thing that I'm really
into called the sensory deprivation
tank.
And the Sempra sensory deprivation tank
was invented by a guy named John Lilly
who was a scientist and a real freak,
like a,
a guy who is just really out there,
really fascinating guy.
And he wrote a book that,
uh,
I picked it up on,
I think like amazon.com like the
used books that they'll sell young,
like people,
sellers,
individual sellers are selling and it's a,
the deep self.
And in it he talks about
the benefits of the tank,
it detailed construction on
how to make your own tank.
He's got like diagrams
in it and just really,
really fascinating guy.
And he was into all sorts of weird
altered states of consciousness.
And one of the things that he wanted
to figure out was how to separate
the body from the senses.
And he came up with a
bunch of different designs.
There's a movie altered states
that's kind of very loosely based on,
you know,
the idea of a guy like him
going completely haywire
and becoming like a monkey.
Just that's how I got into
sensory deprivation tanks.
I saw altered states and they,
they,
they were historically fairly
accurate in the design of the tanks.
The initial one that you saw in altered
states showed what lily at first came up
with,
which was like a glass scuba helmet that
sort of suspended them in regular water
and uh,
he would actually Poop and pee into it.
He had like some crazy filtration system
so he could stay in there and not have
to defecate or urinate.
So it would go through some
system that he had created.
I mean,
this dude was gone.
He was off the deep end.
I mean he's about as off the deep as,
as ever.
But his,
his big thing was to try to figure out
how you can get the mind free of the
influence of the body.
And the best method he came up
to was this idea of the tank.
And he figured out eventually to put salt
water in it and that if you put enough
absence salts,
your body would float and
then he could maintain the,
the heating temperature to essentially
what's the same temperature is just
surface your skin and you wouldn't be
able to recognize where the water was and
it would give you the sensation
of complete sensory deprivation.
And he figured this out.
And from that point on til like,
God,
I don't mean
I met you in,
what was it like how many years ago?
Is it a five or six?
Probably five or six years ago.
Before that,
I had that other gentlemen who,
uh,
used to repair tanks for somebody
who's a great guy and he,
he told me about you and,
uh,
the guy was fixing my Samadi
tank and my somebody tank,
it fucked up something,
something.
It wasn't the tank to
fucked up was the heater,
like it burnt through the,
uh,
the lining of the waterbed and
it's shorted out the whole thing.
It was a disaster.
Like sometimes those
heating yell messages,
they'll pop,
you know,
for whatever reason there's the cook
and it just melted a hole through the
thing.
So he had to repair it,
he to repair the lining and
while he's repairing the lining,
he goes,
you know,
there's this guy in Venice that makes
these like really high tech tanks and he
goes,
you should contact him.
His name is crash.
She's kind of an interesting guy.
And so,
uh,
I s I asked him about it and uh,
he went into depth about all the crazy
shit that you had done to these tanks and
what they looked like.
And he sent me to your
website and I saw the train.
And this is pre the standup tanks.
They were still like smaller like um,
ones like Samadhi.
But way better constructed you,
you had figured out how to do
it where it was just like this,
it looks like a meat locker.
I mean it's so solid and well built and
all your crazy filtration system and
everything.
And I realized that you were this one
lone dude out there who's innovating and
it's sort of forgotten business.
This sort of forgotten aspect of uh,
of,
uh,
of modern day understanding of the mind.
I mean it's really,
it was ignored somehow or another.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know how all these scientists
and geniuses missed out on the sensory
deprivation tank promotion.
They should have been
talking about it everywhere.
It is a mind blowing evolution in,
in meditation.
It's a mind blowing next step in
meditation where you instantaneously go.
If you get good enough at it
and you do it long enough,
you instantaneously can
go to psychedelic states,
intense introspective,
objective,
psychedelic states that are there.
They,
they,
they change your life.
They fundamentally changed
the way you think about life.
And the fact that these people aren't
promoting this because it's not a drug,
it's,
it's totally safe.
It's totally easy to acquire.
It's,
it's totally,
uh,
it,
it ends.
Anytime you want,
you open the door to
get out and it's over.
There's no repercussions.
There's no weirdness to it.
You instantaneously drift back into
normal consciousness that no one's talking
about it.
No one was doing.
And I,
and I found you and Brian
created this a video.
Brian was the guy who made that video
where we went down to the basement and
videotape the,
uh,
the tank.
And,
uh,
from,
from that video on,
we started hearing more and more
people opening up the centers.
They started going crazy.
They started opening up all over the
place and you continue to innovate.
And you haven't said a word yet,
by the way of,
you know.
Well,
no,
I,
even after I'm here,
I'm just nodding my head.
I mean,
you're doing such a good job at the,
uh,
at your appraisal of the situation that,
you know,
I don't want to dilute it.
No,
I,
I just feel like I'm not at all,
no,
I'm really enjoying this because
you are the guy that six years ago,
whatever it was that
first understood that too.
Not only was I out there,
you know,
kinda standing around by myself,
but you know,
when I,
when I found you,
then that really escalated
the exposure in general,
not just isn't for me or it has
to do with the industry overall.
Once that,
you know,
you became,
because you're,
you're an honest guy and your opinion,
people trust it.
And,
and when you say something then that,
uh,
it has a value.
You know,
there's other been people say,
oh,
this,
that whatever,
it doesn't have that,
that sincerity.
The uh,
the true,
uh,
you know,
from,
uh,
what you believe type thing.
It's a lot of times
influenced by this or that.
But once you,
you know,
and,
and you've been,
like I say,
even with the device thing was a big
thing with this in the Hamilton Morris.
It was great.
He's credible.
And without you,
that wouldn't have happened.
You know,
it's just a in that these things help
out everybody right now because the
industry deserves a,
a opportunity to,
uh,
to expand and become available to people
in general because it is an important
thing to a person that's in the process
of considering what it is that they're
doing with themselves,
when,
which I think is very
important for people to,
uh,
take responsibility for
their actions and what,
what,
what they do and what they say.
Cause you know,
you,
you can,
uh,
you're free to do that.
You know,
you're,
you're allowed to be different.
You're allowed to go ahead and say,
you know what?
I don't think this is
quite the way that I,
you know,
in the vista becoming
actually more popular now.
This is like freaky people
that are able to go out say,
oh well hey,
maybe that,
and they're going,
oh yeah,
they're doing all kinds of weird stuff.
I don't even know what a Palati is.
It's catching on,
you know,
there,
I,
you,
I don't know if it's
just our neighborhood or,
right.
It is a labor there.
The different yogas spinning all
these different activities that,
that,
that are,
that people do in a lot of the crossover
to currently it's based on these
athletes that,
that you have contact with or that
respect your perspective or whatever.
And they show up.
That Guy Jeremy Stevens was
here the other day again.
Yeah.
And then I watched him on a clip.
I don't know when that is.
What was fun?
It was this past week that when
he got that guy down fight,
he kicked him and then no,
no,
no.
That was a knock out that he
had in the previous fight.
Man.
I just saw that the other day.
He,
he uh,
did you guys that was in Brazil.
Yeah.
Incredible.
Great Guy.
All those guys smart too.
Oh yeah,
no.
A lot of those guys who were
surprisingly nice and surprising.
Smart.
I think a lot of people have this idea
about people that are involved in combat
sports that they're mean
or they're assholes.
Quite the contrary,
I find you'd be some of the most level,
uh,
well adjusted people that
come in contact with.
They're not trying to prove anything
because they're already secure with who
they are.
Yeah,
they're more level.
That's the best way of of putting it.
Like cause you're forced to get your
ego checked on a super regular basis and
when that happens you kind of,
you just have a better view of things,
you know you don't,
people were constantly afraid of
losing and when you're a fighter,
you lose in the gym all the time
and you kind of mellow that out.
You get an understanding
of who you are and you,
and also the blowing off
of the energy in the gym.
You just see,
feel so much better.
You're more chill,
more relaxed about stuff.
Like a lot of people,
a lot of what their stress
is is that their bodies,
a battery,
their bodies building up all this energy
and it never gets exerted until you're
taken in all this food.
You're,
you're sitting in a cubicle,
you're sitting in your car,
you're sitting at the movies,
you are constantly sitting and not
doing anything and he just irritable.
You're body's just trying to fuck dude,
you fucking move.
Get something going.
Come on,
we've got all this shit pent up and
then someone would get in front of your
traffic.
You know,
when people wonder where
that's coming from,
well that's coming from your,
your all backed up.
You know,
you're,
you are backed.
I know there's nothing scientific
whatsoever to what a trigger is short on.
Some of us,
you know,
pretty uh,
it's also,
you know,
you're not getting your endorphins
and kind of calm you down.
And I think that the tank represents a
level of that in some way that I think
that it's,
it's a thing that should not
just be something that people,
it becomes popular but po something
that it becomes popular in,
in a way where people get a chance to,
to do a new thing that they
could get excited about.
Which is one of the things that
people like with like pilates or yoga,
a new thing that they could be excited
about that could benefit them mentally,
which is where I think we were
missing out on a lot of this stuff.
I think yoga does benefit you mentally.
I think it calms you down and
it's very good for you physically.
But the physical aspect of the
mental aspect coincide with the tank.
It's a hundred percent mental,
it's a weird,
weird experience.
Plus it's available for it for a human
being to actually participate in this
meditation where you sit in a room with
your legs crossed and you're supposed to
check out somehow.
I can't,
I can't do that,
but I go sit in that box for a couple of
few hours and go all kinds of different
things.
Well,
you know the beditation is possible.
I know that there's people that do that,
Kundalini Yoga and they have these
intense psychedelic visions and I believe
that 100% because you,
you,
you do have indogenous chemicals that
the brain produces that can give you
psychedelic experiences like we know
about diamond field trip to me and,
and we know about five minute thoughts.
He'd die muscle the trip to me
being produced by the human body.
So if those are being
produced by the body,
this could easily be some ancient
method of stimulating that production of
releasing some sort of a
burst of that production.
And so these super coon Delaney masters,
which seems like it would be
something you would want to do,
but for whatever reason,
I'm not compelled.
She Shit,
I'm not compelled enough to learn it,
but they can experience natural DMT
trips at the highest levels of their art
form,
which I believe,
I think you just got to get
really good at sitting there.
Then you just get a really
good at yoga positions.
You got to get really good at meditating.
They got to get really good
at just getting good enough
at yoga physically that
you could just sort of
fallen into these forms.
And then when you're falling into these
forms and supporting yourself in some
way by,
by making your body work like that,
you like heightened your expression to
whatever it is that yoga is trying to tap
into.
And it's very psychedelic
but still not the tank.
And it's difficult for me because I'm too,
uh,
too wound up to,
I can't sit somewhere and just sit there.
But,
but if you tried,
maybe you could force yourself.
Yeah,
it would have to force me,
you know?
And I suppose,
do you think that would be good
for you to force yourself to that?
I don't have the,
uh,
the,
it's just not in my,
uh,
my,
another way that I operate,
you know what I mean?
I have a operating,
when I'm awake,
I'm looking at like,
even when I'm out snowboarding
or they're riding my,
whatever,
I don't wear the,
your earphones or whatever,
if I'm right,
I need to listen to what's happening.
Man's
all like all the time.
So it's so distractive,
uh,
in general,
but in their cuts everything off and
I go straight into my head and there's
nothing else there except for that.
I see what you're saying.
Two about the physical.
For some folks they just did not
interested in doing anything that's really
physically strenuous.
I totally understand that.
And that energy winds up being,
they distribute that energy to their work.
Like you do.
Like you're kind of a,
just a mad fiend with your work and your
constant improvements and innovations
to all this stuff.
Like,
you know,
your energy goes where your
energy is probably best suited.
You know,
it's,
it's not the same for everybody.
So what I'm trying to say,
some people have extra time or they're,
they're in the process or a
pursuit and that's a viable,
uh,
method of expression.
That's a good way to meet
chicks with nice legs.
That's what I think [inaudible]
probably the most advantageous.
Otherwise,
why are they going,
where's a beaker of yoga where
it's all sweaty there and there,
there's a 400 degrees and you go,
Oh wow,
this is a lot of fun.
Having sex with a room full of people,
you know,
it's like,
it's the strangest thing ever.
And I see with all these things in mind
that the chamber doesn't sound so bad.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey,
just go in this thing and lay down there
and all of a sudden you'll have the
ability to tap into yourself.
I liked both,
man.
I really do like doing yoga.
We let you go a pump up.
I'm going to get me one of those.
A gorilla,
a couple of those.
A catalog.
I was it.
Yeah.
I like all what you just had to
say about that starts small though.
Yeah,
I can get a baby gorilla or
something to do any exercises.
No nothing.
Nope.
I go up and down the stairs.
That works.
That's something.
Yeah.
And I walk and that is a decision that
people don't realize.
Like if you get to the airport
and every time there's a stairway,
he forced herself to take the stairway.
Every time there's,
you know,
escalator or you avoid that
and get the stares that just,
that alone will make your
trip just slightly better.
Yeah.
Just get a little blood flow in your body.
I that triple sonic too.
Do you ever get on here?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got that.
Yeah.
I got it from you.
That's fine.
I got on that once in a while
cause I don't like that.
That donut top was there.
The muffin,
a muffin top.
I don't like to have that thing so
I gotta make helps you lose weight.
It'll get,
I don't do it,
you know too much for my stomach sit
ups or something like this to try to get
that from a collecting down there.
But standing on that thing,
it kind of helps,
I think at least psychologically believe
it's something undoing for exercise.
Wasn't that thing invented for Russian
cosmonauts to keep them in orbit?
Yeah,
I think that they were uh,
having issues with a muscle deterioration
and the atrophy or whatever.
So they,
uh,
I guess incorporated this a
system of vibration into the,
a strengthening of their
muscles apparently,
but I don't really know.
It seems like,
well where did they take it?
Did they take it up in the ship with
'em or whether it's a good question,
stop off somewhere at the,
at the place,
you know,
in check because you'd have
to have gravity to use it.
Right.
Where's it at?
You know,
sort of electricity seems like a bulky
piece to bring up with you if you're
limited amount of space,
you know,
I don't know.
It doesn't it all also seemed that you um,
if you did use it up in space,
if it wouldn't work.
Yeah.
Cause it shoots you right up.
Maybe who knows who don't
have any resistance.
Yeah.
You have the gravity.
It's like half the thing.
Right.
I think that's the principle
that it's working with
parish then would work fine.
It took a chamber up there to space.
You won't have to use as
much salt there or something.
I think it feels good.
That's why I like it by the
vibrating on it and I don't know.
I don't know if it's to do with anything.
I think I feel it's like a little
body massage when I get on there.
And for folks who don't know what it is,
it's like some sort of a giant
speaker but it doesn't make sound,
it just sends its a,
its such,
so we're describe it
sends like sonic waves,
right?
Yeah.
It moves you up down
and it's the voice coil,
which like us,
it's like a speaker as a voice
call and there's a cone on it.
Then the voice called
moves the cone up and down.
That creates a sound wave.
This is,
those happened,
cone has platform.
So it moves you up and down
if variety of frequency.
So it kind of runs you
through a pattern and yeah.
Then you could dial it up and say,
oh I wanted this is
supposed to do this or that.
You know,
I thought it was gonna be
big a hit be a big hit.
You know,
cause it,
I think it has something to
do with that fat ass syndrome.
You know,
are there people that get
that going on from too much?
Is it stopping off at the wrong places?
You know,
and I don't know if the turtle sign,
I can fix that.
That's a good start to it.
So I think they should,
you know,
eat,
eat less of that shit and
work out a little bit.
But what I do know about
it is whatever it does,
it feels good.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know why it feels good.
I'm not sure,
but it feels like a little,
and you're getting vibrated.
It feels like a little massage.
Like,
ah,
yeah,
you can believe something's happening.
You know,
I don't know exactly what's going on,
but it seems to be something that
was already the variations too.
It's really cool.
It's just a cycle where it'll go really
fast and really slow and then so it
keeps you kind of interested in it.
And it's supposed to,
by doing that,
it's supposed to be stimulating
individual Glam and get your flow going.
You know,
you're uh,
like you were saying about that,
working up like that and you've
got to get your body in motion.
You know,
I think people,
they sit too long in a chair all
day long without moving around.
I don't think it was
probably not that good.
Yeah,
we've talked about it a million times.
The whole thing is just
sitting in an office as a fucking
terrible way to live your life.
It's supposed to be super bad for you.
As I sit in an office,
well,
you know,
it's a wheel.
They do it at like three hours at a pop.
And even then I get up and I'm like,
I have an office.
I sit in my office every day,
all day long and going to get
out of it and go back to it.
You know,
in our office is how you set it up.
I think.
See this is okay to sit around here.
This is a fine office.
Sorry.
Nice.
Is it that they get that they're horrible.
Lied.
And then there's this,
there's the,
there's the rules and
you've got a suit on.
You know,
they're sitting in the office.
The whole thing represents a bummer.
Do you think you have to do that
to people to get them to work?
Do you have to make them wear
a suit to get them to work?
I mean if you,
if you let people wear t
shirts and jeans and shit,
would they take insurance
as seriously as they do?
If they're aware,
that goofy monkey suit,
you know,
would they stick to the company line
when they're on the phone giving those,
uh,
those pep speaks.
You wonder what image
they're trying to project.
What is it you're trying to,
you know,
sends Guy Mr. Crash.
Yeah.
Well,
I look at my tie and I never
swear why when I'm at the office,
I'm completely approved
and I'm leaving these guys every time
because I just don't think that that's who
I want to be doing anything with is
these characters that are not working on
their own,
uh,
you know,
uh Oh there for these
guys or those who are you?
What do you want?
What's your story?
Well,
these guys were those guys,
you know what I mean?
You're working for somebody and you're,
that's why you're showing
up in a tie and a suit,
or you have a bunch of people working
for you and you want to look the role.
Yeah,
you got to look at,
I'm here to sell insurance was to crash.
I'm a no nonsense guy.
Look at my cuff there.
Perfect.
There's guys that do those
commercials on the TV,
a rich person or whatever it is.
They're all like at my boat.
All right,
for these houses everywhere.
And I got a yacht,
looked at all mine,
all this stuff.
I got,
I am living well,
just go ahead and meanwhile I'm standing
here in this terrible auditorium with a
bunch of you and this is what begging
for you maybe to give me some of your
money so I can continue on with my maybe,
maybe not lifestyle that you know.
Yeah,
there's a lot of those weird guys that
are like motivational speakers and they
motivate you to come to their seminars
and they make a fuck load of money from
your,
from your mind.
You're like,
wait a minute that you had a boat fishing.
What's going on?
And it seems like you were still
hanging out here at this place.
This is a bummer in here.
I can hardly wait to leave.
This is your day,
you know you're getting,
yeah.
It's not the best way to live life for me.
No,
I'm glad someone's doing it.
Always doing it.
We would not have apple computers.
You would not have Samsung phones.
You would not have Audi cars.
He wouldn't have these things.
If somebody wasn't out there busting
their ass every day in an office,
people like it.
Some people are suited for that type of a,
of a,
of a lifestyle.
So maybe if we reach too many people
with this message of get your shit
together,
it'd be terrible for
civilization as a whole.
Overall,
this one would weaken us and like the
Chinese would take over all this could be
low.
It's going to be a
factor for that.
I mean,
we're fucking it up.
We're fucking it up with these goddamn
isolation tanks and these medical
marijuana dispensaries,
oh,
those are wonderful to reach the next day.
I don't want to live are unnatural life.
How are you going to continue to build
these buildings and launch these missiles
if we don't continue to
live on unnatural life?
The more we tune in to the natural life,
the more we see how ridiculous
it is when we wake up.
It's coming our way.
I think that people are
coming around right now.
It's happening.
I think it is.
I think you're right.
If you look at it like
America is important,
you know,
even though I,
I don't have a flag or nothing like that,
but,
but it,
it's where we live and it's kind of like
where we're from and it's sort of like
what we're supposed to be,
uh,
you know,
proud about and you're supposed to say,
oh,
I'm from here.
And I'm really glad about that because
where it is and the way they operate,
I'm Po,
I go along with that.
But it's gotten too far now in my opinion,
which is,
you know,
everybody's gone.
It needs to get to where the people
actually get an overview again,
where they start to evaluate situations
and then make correct decisions based on
now instead of like these prehistoric,
uh,
versions of what's got
us to here need to be,
uh,
you know,
hopefully at some point let go with
and get a new evaluation that's,
that's,
uh,
pertains to where we're
at now in the world.
What can we do now to
get along with people?
How can we work together this,
even if these military see what the,
I think that we sell a lot
of guns in this country and,
uh,
in pharmaceuticals.
So he said,
oh,
I don't think we're going to get out
of the bomb business because it's our
business,
you know,
so we have to figure out how
to get these guys working,
doing something good,
you know,
so we don't like say,
Oh,
all your jobs are gone now.
Figure out how we could go
in and do stuff together.
Use our money and our resources to
create situations that are beneficial for
people.
They're not gonna,
we're not gonna make friends
by shooting at people.
We all know that.
And I mean,
this is,
you know,
this is some kind of a fictitious,
uh,
a concept that we can go over
and make people happy by,
by killing them.
You know what I mean?
Well,
the concept of war being for financial
benefit is still pretty alien to a lot of
folks.
They don't believe it.
They don't believe that
that's why wars are started.
Yeah.
Well,
what all you'd have to consider is how
much benefit there could have been done
to America.
I mean,
if you're really a pro America
person and you really are a patriot,
think about what a,
what a benefit it would have been to
America to take a lot of that money that
went to this crazy war that
no one believes in anymore.
And try to clean up inner cities,
try to fix Chicago,
try to fix,
fix the border towns,
try to help Mexico.
How dangerous.
We have a dangerous situation
like a hundred miles from us.
I mean,
what,
what the fuck is that?
You go to what it would it?
How long?
How far is it to San Diego?
It's two hours.
So what does that 120 miles,
something like that to 40 I
think it's and are nearby.
How fast you going,
bitch?
You're not going 130 miles an hour and
you fucking retard when 41 4,140 miles.
Okay,
so 70 miles an hour for two hours.
That's Mexico.
That's crazy.
It's a two hour drive to third
world country that's in turmoil.
And we don't do a God damn thing about
it and we're sending people to someplace
that's so far removed from us that just
coincidentally happens to have oil.
That's not why we're here.
That is not why we're here,
Mr. Crash,
we're here to fix things like oil.
Fig is a funny one.
I got a mess over here.
We have all these people that killed
people in New York City from Saudi Arabia,
but we need to get over
here and over here.
Do you know what?
I don't believe that oil is fossil fuel.
They say,
oh,
it's from a fossil.
You Think,
oh,
I got fossils.
They're rocks.
You know what I mean?
It's pressure under the ground said,
oh,
so in other words,
he used to be the same dinosaurs
out in the middle of the ocean.
Well,
I don't think,
do you think his last class anymore?
I think they think it's rotten plankton.
Yeah.
If at the top
of the frozen Alps and the bottom of the
ocean and over here in the desert and
everywhere,
at one time there was
plankton all over it,
an hour or whatever to make these
gigantic puddles of this stuff that we're
pumping out for some reason.
And then you say,
oh look,
step back and say,
but from an alien,
what are those guys doing down there?
Well,
you know,
they're,
they're pumping this stuff out of there,
the oil they call it,
and then they turn it into a,
a plastic material that,
that litters the planet.
They can't get rid of it or they take
it and then they burned it into the
atmosphere and poisoned themselves.
And then,
and then what they do,
they spend all their money to fight
amongst each other to see who gets control
of it.
And you're thinking this whole
stuff isn't really that necessary.
It could be done without
back to the hemp again,
look at that hemp,
but what it has to
offer computer speaking.
Well,
it's just too hard,
too difficult to control.
You know,
there was a book on the process of,
of,
of oil being developed that they were
trying to speculate somehow or another
that it was,
um,
that it was developed through a
natural process and the earth.
And they were saying that our
ideas of it were incorrect,
but I don't think it was well received.
I have the books,
I never read it.
I bought it and I was like,
I'm going to read that one day and it
just sat there and never fucking read it.
I just couldn't get behind it.
It's just seemed,
it seemed kind of goofy that anybody
wouldn't have figured that out by now.
Exactly where you're going.
Wow.
That thing about the planets to how
they're supposed to be circumcised and the
earth.
What the sun,
let's say the sun's moving,
right?
This is going this way.
So now they have a believer though
that planets are circling the sun.
Is it?
I think that this makes more sense to me.
And there's other,
you know,
this isn't my thought,
but somebody showed,
oh yeah,
that makes me say this
sun is going this way.
Well,
what makes us think we're not in rotation
in a vortex being pulled by the sun
going somewhere.
I think we're,
we're on a trip,
man.
We're going.
So we started off where,
where was the sun a hundred
years ago and where's it at now?
And then where are we
going to be later on?
I believe the sun is pulling
us through space and were in,
well that's not a belief.
That's a fact.
That's that's absolutely what's happening.
The whole galaxies moving.
Yeah.
No,
this is something that,
uh,
astrophysicists have
figured out a while ago.
So at the whole universe is kind of
moving that just have expansion thing.
I don't know.
I think we're going galaxies moving.
I think we're going in
a direction somewhere.
I think that if we figured out where's
The sun and where is it off too.
I think we're behind it.
I think that we're following it
and this is the way the rotation,
I don't know which way
is up or down in here.
Where's the north south?
That is exactly how it's
supposed to be described.
I think as it goes,
you know,
we're circling around it.
I think we're going to run it this way.
I don't know.
I'm too fucking stupid.
I don't understand it at all.
I mean when I watched those
scientific documentaries on space,
it's one of the most fascinating things
ever and most fascinating so that it's
so rarely brought up in
regular conversation.
That's where some of this money
should go into like expansion of the,
of the reality situation.
We're in here.
They said,
oh look,
we have this and that
we can think about now,
get these scientists challenge
to put the phone down.
First off,
put
this on down enough on the phone
is Jaeger counter designer.
It tells you the name of the tune it's on.
You know,
it's like,
okay,
it's a fun and nobody answers it,
which is what really freaks me out,
man.
I got it.
Cause I've got to call everybody at night.
Say,
Hey,
don't forget to come down tomorrow.
I know I made an appointment,
but I'm convinced that you're not
going to be able to remember it.
So I'm calling you now to say,
Oh hey,
don't forget I get 20% people
answered the phone said,
Oh yeah,
no problem.
Got It.
The other 80% is a me leaving a message,
you know,
which I can't stand leaving a message,
but I'm thinking they
got it in their hand.
They had it right here.
They got,
how aren't they answering the phone?
It's a phone.
Hello?
Yeah,
but don't you think it's good that
there's all these capabilities of these
things have smart phones?
I think it's good to ever people,
other people have them bitcoin on it.
You can,
you can check out an email
link that somebody sends you.
You don't think that's good.
I think it's good for,
you know,
you know people that want to do that.
Oh,
I think it's good.
I just think the problem is overused.
The problem is over
use of anything though.
It's overuse of softball.
If you just became a fucking softball
junkie and you're out there on the field
every day,
throwing that ball in the air,
hitting them by herself
into a tree and people like,
what is Tom Doing?
Can't wait for that
fucking game on Sunday.
Jesus Christ.
Tom,
you got a family and
he had a wife at home.
Get home.
You know,
you're obsessing,
you're freaking people out,
man.
I think that's bad too.
But I think the phone in
moderation is a a beautiful thing.
And basing how much scientifical uh,
advancements they've done
on the phone in the past,
how many years,
if they quit that kind of
brain power into anything.
We're driving the same car almost.
I could assemble this.
Got a pretty new thing,
some kind of motorized or,
but it's pretty similar
to the cars that we had.
I was just talking with a friend last
night about how like the cars of 10 years
ago when I was a kid,
when I was in high school,
I was in high school.
I was 14 in 1984.
That's when I was at nine or
1981 when I was in high school.
And um,
there was a uh,
uh,
1970 Chevelle that this kid
had that was in my school.
And uh,
I guess he was like maybe
two years older than me,
so he might've been like 16 but you have
this 1970 Chevelle and everybody was
like,
Holy Shit,
look at that.
It was a classic.
So 70 Chevelle,
SS,
three 50 years old.
It's only 11 years old.
Like how was the car?
11 years old.
Like a classic back then,
but an 11 year old car today,
it's like,
you know,
it's not that big of a deal.
You know,
if you got a hold of a,
would that be a 2003,
2003 car?
And that's like,
it's a modern car.
Like what happened?
How'd that,
how'd that have dropped the ball?
Something happened.
They might've hit like
some sort of technological,
they're constantly pushing the
boundaries as far as like this,
this speed that cars can go and the g
forces that they can handle and like to
get like the track times get
a little bit better every year
with their sports cars.
But for the average regular car,
like at a certain point in time,
what else can you improve?
You going to add some electronic
blocks that were up there.
Those people that got that a road,
they made those tiles that light up.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The solar or road panels.
Incredible.
Incredible,
incredible.
Lights the city up like tron and stuff
and they're collecting energy in the car
and they could,
that could totally be implemented to
apparently that's completely realistic.
It's crazy.
Were there already,
we just have to get,
get,
get somebody to say,
you know,
a hike.
Do you know how weird do you
know weird city streets look?
Can you imagine if you lived in the
time before electricity and then someone
brought you to New York City Times
Square Saturday night and you're walking
through and you see all these lights
and all this craziness and the cars with
the lights and you're like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe this.
That would be like a really
intense sort of a change.
But I wonder if it would be as
intense as all the roads being lit,
all the roads being lent to us right now.
That might be like we
might not be able to,
we might have to address the
fact that we live in the future.
Like if all of our fucking row,
I mean we might have all
collectively just go,
what the fuck are we doing?
Look what we're doing.
We have solar powered roads.
That's progress.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And not breaking down or they
have alternative purposes.
They're not only to drive on,
but they have other information.
They change would be so strange though.
The way it would alter our our world,
like our vision of the world would look
totally different if Hong Kong was lit
up with those kinds of,
I wonder what the effect would be w
I feel like it would make people more
festive.
It,
you know,
I feel where,
I mean you're driving
on this road already.
If these cars are just trying to
tune yourself out because of the,
it's such a tedious process to get from
point a to point B in a car is gray and
there's other people jammed up in there
and the speed's not what you like or
whatever,
you know.
So it's kind of a,
the transportation,
I think they got some room
to improve on that for us.
You know,
if they,
if they put the phone down,
yeah.
If they put the phone down,
I get to concentrate and it's
helping them communicate though.
Maybe they can use the
phone to make the cars.
Yeah.
This is the roadways.
These are sole roadways.
Is that guys Zach,
he was over the other
day something we said.
We looked him up to see what he says.
He's on the silicone
valley show or something,
so we'd want to see what you say.
He's a funny guy,
but anyway,
I wanted to see,
what is this show?
Silicone Valley.
I never seen the show.
Funny show.
It's on HBO.
I've only,
I only watched one episode.
It was really funny.
We brought it up and there he was and
he's getting the car came to pick him up.
If he looks in there and there's like,
I said,
oh,
you got it in the card,
it's nobody in there.
And he says,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to wherever it was.
And then the car took off
all by itself driving it,
you know?
Yeah.
Well they're going to have that.
I mean they've,
they essentially have that now,
the Google cars where they're
experimenting with it and they,
they haven't had any accidents.
None of the accidents that they've been
involved with have been the Google cars
fault.
I think a few people bumped into
him jump out in front of them or no,
no,
that they haven't hit anything,
but they apparently have radar.
They can sense when things
are in front of you.
I mean,
you've seen that in cars.
When you get close to
the car in front of you,
it'll make like a BPPP.
I rented a car this weekend that does it.
They park themselves now.
Some cars,
yes,
they can parallel park themselves,
park itself,
which is ridiculous.
They just decided you motherfuckers
are too stupid to do this.
We have to help you.
Excellent.
This is where I want the money for my
car that I'm going to buy to be invested
in the ability of it to then park itself.
It's,
you know what?
There's the thing that's going on right
now where people are trying to go retro
with a lot of Shit because like there's
a lot of people that like old cars now.
There's a lot of people that like,
like refurbished things because
they don't want any of that.
They don't want all of that interference.
They don't want all of that disconnect
between them and an actual machine.
We just kept work on it.
You're,
you're a car guy.
You look under a car lid
now you're looking at it.
There you go.
What is under here now?
This shit with trunk or
is the motor in here?
I don't even know which,
which,
which on this thing yet.
You know if you can pop the
hood of a 1970 Chevelle,
you get in that man.
You got a wrench out attributor cap.
It's right there.
You can grab it with your hand.
There's your oil filter.
You could hold onto it cause the dipstick,
you could see how much
oil is in there with us.
You've got computers,
you have to run it.
Shut it off.
Cancers guy.
You have to have a guy.
Yeah,
you have to have a gun.
The think a computer
can go wacky on you too.
That also can happen.
That happens occasionally.
I mean obviously this is
mechanical breakdown too,
but computers can go,
wow,
you're a guy's guy.
After you get a guy then
he has to have a guy said,
hey,
oh yeah,
my stuff isn't correctly.
But on the flip side you
have navigation screens,
you have backup cameras,
you have all this cool shit
that electronics provide to.
It's,
I see both sides of it.
But like I do see like the appeal
of like driving an old VW bug,
like a VW bug from like 1970,
not much horsepower or anything,
but man,
what a,
what a connection you have to
the road with that piece of shit.
You know,
it's not good at handling,
it doesn't have good brakes,
but you know,
when you see one,
this is like a little bit and driving it.
Yeah.
I wish I could drive one of the
greater good of the project.
My friend Jimmy had when
we were in high school,
I was an idiot.
I always had muscle cars and my friend
Jimmy had this VW bug and it was like,
you know,
we,
like I said,
this is right out of high school.
So I,
I graduated in 85 and
Jimmy was ahead of me.
And so I think that it was probably like
1986 or something along those lines.
And uh,
he had this 1960 something bug or 69 bug,
ugly light blue,
you know.
But it was great.
It was something cool about it.
It was like we had a big smile on our
face when we're driving around in it.
You know there was something about,
yeah,
first of all he's like,
you know macho guy
and a is a construction worker.
He's just really smart dude too though.
So he got himself a fucking
VW bug and he's like,
it gets great gas mileage but like the
wind would blow and the car would move.
Like you could feel the car
moving if a good breeze hit it.
Like she'll fucking cars
moving from the wind man.
Like what do we do and
we're going to go cart.
Yeah,
they do handle better now.
Cars.
Oh one time.
That's,
that's the understatement of the year.
Snowboard,
right go.
Amazing prize by break.
I had to stop from like 65 to zero like
like on the freeway the other day and it
just was like,
no,
you have the tweet,
that sweet new Volkswagen that's like,
or it's perfect.
I forgot you had that perfect
contrast to the Volkswagen.
Then we were talking to him about it
because my friend Jimmy's Volkswagen was
like super old school.
Like that lawn mower engine.
It sounds like a lawnmower
or sewing machine.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You'd have to pump the brakes,
but it was like a really light tiny car.
Where's the new one?
Like we're saying it looks
like a like a fat Porsche.
It looks like a like some sort of a
space shit like an Audi or something like
that.
The new VW bug is pretty dope looking.
They,
they pretty much redesign it for guys
and they got rid of all the girls shit in
it like that.
The flower ponds and shit like that.
That used to be in the old ones,
like more ones that look like bubbles
and it's a perfect example of a car that
like shows the improvement
of today's cars because the,
the performance and handling of a VW
bug is better than like a 1970 Portia.
If you got a Porsche from
1970 those bitches had like
skinny ass steering wheels
that were big like Hula hoops
and get shitty ass skinny tires.
Like they,
they didn't handle that well.
They just weren't that good in comparison
to like what your car could do if you
brought your car back in time.
Like when they had the 1969 Porsche
and you showed them your car,
they'd be fucking blowing you.
It was gonna be like you're
a wizard from the future.
Yeah.
This is the 2014 turbo.
I have this car,
but doesn't it have like 250
horsepower or something like that?
They just put a new engine in it.
I forget what exactly it is.
Fuck fat.
Like that was a big deal.
Like to have,
I mean that would be a little bit
heavier than an old Porsche for sure,
but if you could get that kind
of horsepower in an old car,
I mean that's ridiculous.
Like they have these new mustangs,
the Mustang Gt,
the new one that's out just straight
Mustang gt has like 450 fucking horsepower
or something crazy like that.
There's songs out to people on.
Oh yeah,
but that's like their basic car.
Then they have a Shelby that comes out
later that's going to have more than 600
horsepower like that wasn't accessible
back in 1970 second place to go drive
these things.
Say,
hey look,
we got a place you can go drive it to
get something even remotely as fast in
like 1970 you had a special order shit.
You had to go to a mechanic,
you got to find some dude who knows
how to put in nitrous on a car,
but now you get his buy it.
They allow people to
have something like that.
Well,
it's just a faction of what
we're doing at faction.
This can can continual improvement.
This,
it's a a a process and it's
a product of those things.
It's a product of this
continual improvement and it's
a product of our constant
desire for new shit.
We want the car that does zero to 60 in
3.4 because the car does zero to 60 in
3.6 is outdated and you look at the specs,
oh,
this car went around the Nurburgring
and seven minutes and 25 seconds.
People Freak out.
They go,
I can't believe that my car
does it in seven 40 my car
piece of shit.
You're like,
asshole,
you're not going around the Nurburgring
like what are you doing man?
Like if you drove my
friend Jimmy's Vw bug,
that might make you feel better than
driving some ridiculous car that goes zero
to 60 in two seconds
and corners at two g's.
You know it well,
it's a certain,
a certain part of that.
You'll lose the fun.
There's like a fun and driving.
You know there's a guy named Dario,
Fran Cheaty,
I think you say his name.
He's a race car driver and he drives a,
his,
his cardio is fun car to drive.
He's like a 1973 Porsche
with like a big engine in it.
He put like a more modern
engine in 1973 boards.
Like he could get like a vague Iran or
any of these like super complicated cars
they're making today.
But a guy who's an actual race car driver
decided to go for like the gritty feel
of an old car combined
with modern technology.
He's a very smart guy,
you know,
he's like all these zero to
60 times she goes is yes,
it's important where your race car driving
but not for the pleasure of driving.
So that's the guy listened to.
I mean that's the guy,
he does it for a living.
So if he chooses to drive like
an old car that like really,
you really feel everything,
that's probably the most pleasure.
A lot of merit.
Yeah.
We like pass the pleasurable point and
went to some weird numb point with cars
where the stealings like this and
you don't feel any of the bumps,
you know?
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's not organic.
You know,
it's kind of not organic.
It's not very Mumford and sons.
Yeah.
It's not very,
uh,
yeah.
That's the trend today.
The trend today is to go
with like a handmade clock,
you know,
like,
oh see that clock.
It was handmade.
And people like,
Ooh,
you know,
there's something cool about that as
opposed to like if you lived in 1970 and
you've got a digital clock,
you were the pimp of the year.
Like this guy said,
digital clock in his house,
you go over a dude's house and
he had digital alarm clock.
He would like this motherfucker's got a
digital alarm clock and it was to raise
a microwave oven.
Ellie.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I remember going over people's
houses and they had that.
I was,
I couldn't believe I was looking at it.
I was looking at,
then he came in to watch.
Yeah.
At first I got the clock in your
house and put it on your hand.
Pam.
Six 44 ethic.
That's what people are saying.
Hey,
what time is it?
Oh,
it's seven 60 and remember
the batteries were such dog
shit that you,
you had to press it to find the time and
then you'd let it go and fuck your time
would go by president.
It didn't just stay on because it was,
the batteries were dog shit back then.
You know,
if it was going to stay on it,
we had to be like a a foot thick.
The battery for that back then.
Yeah.
I mean there's batteries
were just dog shit,
but I never thought about that.
I mean those were,
it's remember the calculator watch for
some reason that one never took off.
He took off and it got to a
certain point and people are like,
wait,
wait.
What the,
how often am I counting shit.
They've got the calculator phone.
Your phone is kind of a computer.
That's a one device choice.
You better off with a compass.
What if you get lost?
All you got is a fucking tie.
Calculate a bitch.
Calculators not going to help
you if you're lost in the woods.
Boy,
yeah,
you have something to make some fire.
Yeah.
Why do you got to fucking calculator?
Not that as our first development here
and it's also the calculator watch was
invented with calculators
were only like that big like,
I mean,
what the fuck are you doing?
How often is that coming up?
Except this is the one thing that I
know people were probably yelling at me
right now except people
cheating in school.
I bet there was a window.
I bet there was a small window where
teachers are still fucking old people who
are there.
They're out of touch with modern
technology and a lot of ways.
So there's probably a window with these
young little rascals went in there with
their technological wizard phones
with calculators on and they probably,
I remember doing that totally.
How long was it before
they were made illegal?
Do you remember that
he ever really wear,
I don't think they ever actually caught
on because you were always allowed to
use like calculators to cheat in school.
There was this big Tia 81 Texas
instrument ones that you had to buy.
Remember this huge calculators
and you used to be,
there was a note field kind of where you
can just sit there and write all these
like pro like answers to
questions in the calculator.
And the teachers never
caught on for us on that.
We just opened up all,
everyone would open up their calculators
and look at our notes on there.
Oh no,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
so it was like,
I'm like a a note
function on a smartphone.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
It was.
It was like the beginning of that.
But I remember calculator watches like
we had them and I don't ever remember
being told not to wear it.
Like I don't think the,
even the math teachers
even figured it out.
Well let's,
let's Google that to find out.
Cause I would think that the only way
to get good at math if you're going to
really get good at math is you
have to actually do it right?
I mean yeah,
math is something that's fun to do.
I mean I think when the
question is terrible,
he just lost all credibility.
I don't know who you are
and what you just said.
I like it because it's
like always the same way.
Watch this spelling.
But then you start getting
into triangles and shit.
He needs that.
Well that's specialized mathematical,
just like addition man.
It's like Harry Potter Science,
like those guys,
the quantum,
the quantum deep into the
quantum consciousness as I
liked those guys that say
shit that I can't understand it all.
I love when they're talking
to that kind of math,
when they show me those
mathematical and you just go,
what is that?
An alien language.
Like,
what is that?
I have no idea what that is.
Those guys fascinated me in the movie.
They see that the,
there's a cartoon where
they're all looking at that,
the big formula on the chalkboard
or over there and they're going,
huh?
Cause there's a humor.
Some are in the normal,
there was the joke in the a formula
that a irregular persons knocking.
It's not funny.
You know
Joe,
do you remember glacier?
I think they're called glacier glasses.
They can't,
there were out around the same time.
There were like,
like circle glasses,
but then they had this little leather
piece that went on the side and then like
the,
the arms were like may not a rubber and
they were really popular for like two
years in the early eighties
and they were like,
I missed the,
I didn't hang out with
any of those people.
Look at Google calculator,
watch Matt.
It's actually pretty trippy.
They came out with one in 1975 man,
none nuts.
I had one in one of the one really
eighties calculator watch were first.
It were first introduced in the 1970s
and despite enjoying a heyday during the
1980s continued to be produced.
The most notable brand
is Casio databank series.
The watches were buy Timex.
We're also popular.
There's a Wikipedia,
but Brian has a Wikipedia where you
could see all the old ones there.
It's a trip,
man.
It's really fascinating.
Like I forgot how silly
these things where,
Oh yeah,
look at those.
We'll look at the one down looking
at the one even further down.
Look at that thing.
How do you get your
finger on one of those?
But that's all you got to get a little.
Remember that at all.
But with that is the future of ad.
If you had one of those,
you could totally get star wars.
Chicks.
Chicks are like really into star wars.
They would think you were so cool.
He's got a fucking calculator on his rest.
It's so future.
It's so space.
Yeah.
That didn't work out.
We didn't give a fuck anymore.
Now people went back to dials.
You know like if your car is fancy,
your car has an old school clock on it.
Like if you buy a Lexus
or something like that,
they'll have like a nice clock in it.
Like an actual tick tick tock.
Yeah,
and it's to show you,
this is a luxury item sir.
There's no digital clocks in here,
sir.
This is a luxury item
isn't it?
Is it is just a thing that tells the
time like what the fuck is going on here?
Something's going on here.
If you have a tick tock,
tick tock,
it's fancy.
See this?
This is fancy.
This is fancy and can't hear.
This is how I know what time where I look
at my computer go away or the computer
or was he a digital numbers?
Your exact numbers.
I like looking at it.
We the court Sansi too,
right?
I don't know what's in there.
I got that shit at target.
I don't know what it is.
It's just a clock,
but I like looking at a
clock for whatever reason.
It gives me a better sense of what
time is that when I look at a number,
when I look at numbers and
it's totally illogical,
but I look at this number,
my computer,
the upper left hand or upper
right hand corner of my computer,
and then I look at that,
that's more pleasurable
to me for whatever reason.
That's an interesting uh,
evaluation.
I think I have a more natural
sense of analog thing.
Yeah.
You know,
the way analog is better than tape to
you listening to recordings and so forth
like that.
A lot of times,
you know,
it used to record and uh,
analog and then they went to digital,
came out Kinda then.
Then what they would do
is they'll go digital,
analog,
digital and then back to analog.
Yeah.
Try to mix this stuff
up to where it sounds.
Uh,
and I fully understand that.
For some folks it's the opposite.
Some folks they don't like that,
that's not pleasing to them,
but they love the numbers.
Some,
I mean it's all different.
It's just me personally.
That's how I always feel when I,
I would way rather look at like a,
I think clocks are kind of cool.
Whenever I look at a watch,
pardon me goes,
oh that's cool.
Can Watch the other part
of me instantaneously goes,
it is so God damn fascinating.
There's a bunch of moving parts in there.
Amazing.
That's spin and took like,
I'm not a fan of expensive watches,
I'm not,
I mean I think some of
them look really cool,
but it's not something that I'm really
into because they seem to me like peacock
feathers a little bit.
But what I am a fan of is the
engineering behind those watches.
I'm a fan of like my watch has done,
uh,
it's,
it's just not an expensive watch at all,
but it,
it kind of like at
nighttime it kind of glows.
Like I could see that the,
the uh,
the hand very clearly at nighttime,
it's a fantastic feature.
It doesn't require a battery to do that
either or it doesn't run on any extra,
you know,
sounded like your thing,
you have to do press a button or anything.
You can always see it.
But I'm fascinated by that.
I'm fascinated by the
engineering involved in it.
But I think for a lot of guys they were,
and I'm not criticizing,
they look cool as fuck,
but it seems very kind of peacocky,
you know,
when dudes have like diamonds all
over their watch and you know,
diamonds and they thing,
and my buddy Alex watch this,
he's just,
he's showing me a watch $36,000 for,
it's a watch.
I was looking at it going,
Oh man,
you know,
and I met a guy that had one in Toronto,
I think it was like more
than a hundred thousand.
I'm trying to remember what he will own.
Like a company that imports them.
Very,
very nice guy.
He loves watches.
Oh yeah.
There's people that are
into collecting watches,
you know,
and they're very,
a matter of fact about their watches,
you know,
they say,
oh,
this is a Hamilton from it.
You know,
there's a,
they have a,
it's like the cars and
watches are another quality,
you know,
like a good watch.
You like you said,
it's a Swiss engineer.
It's a,
it's a piece of stuff that,
that,
that lasts.
It's not a piece of
junk that's disposable.
You get a piece of quality,
you know,
it's watch and it's got a lot of work put
into it and it's something you'll have
forever,
you know?
And I liked that and stuff.
That's electronics probably have the um,
the quickest turnaround as far as
like when they kind of go on you like,
I've never had a computer
last more than five years,
but I've had watches that
last like 20 years through.
I've watched this 20 years old.
20.
Yeah.
It's 20 years old.
People got their grants
not expensive either.
Just a regular watch
and it's,
it's like when my battery
dies or just buy a new one.
Yeah.
I mean you can totally do that.
You can put another battery in
that watch you divide your watch,
you said.
Yeah.
Every time it the battery dies.
I'm just like,
I was going to do watch you is
the one that did that to us.
They started the,
the the lighter as you throw it out.
Then they got the Shaver,
you throw it out,
then a w what was your pen?
You throw it out.
You remember that?
It was all big,
big started with the throwaway stuff
and then now it's like their phone goes
down,
you throw it out,
the TV goes out,
anything goes out,
you throw it out.
I mean,
yeah,
we should really reevaluate,
reevaluate the whole
throwing out plastic shit.
You see all the plastic that's in the
ocean and all these photographs of these
birds that had been feeding plastics to
their babies and their babies die and
you see that their bellies
are filled with plastics.
You know,
it's fucking shit up lately is these,
uh,
those facial cleaners that have the
little beads in them that just these tiny
little plastic beads,
I guess they're fucking
up the water and air
biodegradable.
Those things.
There's scrubs and you know what?
They don't need to use those scrubs.
You can use seeds.
There's seeds that you can get like um,
apricots,
facial scrub,
like it's an apricot seed and it's
just as good and it's biodegradable,
like all these little plastic
things like so unfortunate man,
but a lot of that,
oh,
those,
those goggles.
Glasses do not.
I remember having my calculator watch
and these glasses were really popular.
They're called,
they were called something
awesome like douchebag,
Google glasses,
but it was a guy wore them
start,
start date or something.
Maybe
they had,
they had leather on the glasses.
It's like your car's had brawls on them.
It's just like,
we had this weird leathers.
Oh yeah,
you remember the Bronx who
we should bring that back.
I think some people still do it,
man.
I saw a guy with a corvette
day at a bra and a corvette.
I was like,
wow,
you're rocking a brand new corvette.
Part was an old corvette.
Wasn't real leather though.
It was it.
I don't know.
I didn't ask you.
That's a can of worms.
You don't really want to open up.
No.
I know.
Supra brought on my super
course not that was the shit.
Yeah,
I think I had a bra once,
but I think I got rid
of it pretty quickly.
I was like,
what is this stupid fucking thing?
What am I doing here?
That's what I'm saying.
There was a weird time in
the 80s that the leather,
like there was no reason
to have leather on you.
Like look the big chunks
of leather on your glasses.
I guess the idea is
you want something soft that does.
That doesn't take light in from the sides,
but that also fuck up your peripheral.
May you very susceptible to hooks.
Yeah.
They should bring back the plastic
covering for the couches now.
Oh,
that was a dream.
When people,
you go over their house and it
was covered with clear plastic.
Sit down.
It's at grandma's house.
This is that everyone was wanting to
keep things serving on for so long that
they never enjoyed them
when they had them.
Shit wasn't disposable.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
You come in there and
the mom's telling you,
hey,
you can't walk in that room.
It's all this way or that people,
some people still have towels like that
and that's what's used those towels.
Get them out of here.
There's little soaps.
Oh,
you didn't use the,
here's the AML.
So now that the little
a frog that was there,
how he could you do that?
You know,
you guys are freaks.
Yeah.
The toddler was for freak.
Say up doctor.
It's a prop.
You been messing with the
bathroom props in here,
you know?
Yeah.
They're trying to paint some
sort of a crazy environment.
Oh,
cleaver.
Cleaver.
Uh,
what's her name?
Joan.
What's Ms Cleavers name?
Um,
I don't remember.
It was ward.
Leave it to ward.
Ward was the daddy.
When was it?
June.
Was it June cleaver?
It was mrs cleavers thing.
It wasn't she the best.
Barbara Billingsley I think.
Yeah.
Okay.
June cleaver.
I think it was.
And I think you're right.
Yeah.
Remember Eddie Haskell?
I remember 80 half.
Yeah,
it was June cleaver.
She was wonderful.
What a crazy fucking show.
You imagined that there was a show that
they made and it's called leave it to
beaver.
And it was an actual show.
And the kid's name was beaver.
And at what point in Tom did they
realize that that means pussy?
Was it like it started in the 1950s right.
So what,
you know,
first appearance was a,
it was a pilot that they made in
1957 so when did beaver become,
when did it become a vagina?
Was that the 70s you think?
I don't know.
Maybe because everyone thought beaver was
just like a pussy and so they just put
it together cause he had played
it like a pussy character,
you know,
be where was,
well he wasn't,
he's getting beat up.
It wasn't a savage.
Yeah,
I thought it was because
of his teeth or something.
I thought he had like a beaver,
a facial,
a look or something.
Hmm.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Really?
Yeah.
This thing they did,
I really can't get named it
after their teeth or something.
It'd be her,
I don't know.
I don't think so.
The beaver,
the beef,
where did that come from?
I think that was just his nickname.
How did he get it?
What did they say?
Oh yeah,
you smell bad or what?
I don't.
They looked at the time
before the Internet.
It's like second was a slang
term from the 1910 England.
Have you ever tried to watch that?
You ever tried to watch
leave it to beaver?
I grew up on it.
We can get back to isolation
tank talking a couple minutes.
We have plenty of time
release and gentlemen.
But seeing as how we're
in the flow of this,
I would like to watch a little quick
leave it to beaver episode just to see how
ridiculous the world
was in 1957 real quick.
Even the opening when they have
their house and it's all nice.
We probably Dennis the menace.
Remember Mr. Wilson,
he was over there and he was like,
oh John,
you manis or whatever you say.
She and Mr. Wilson,
they used to talk to each other.
It was so alien.
People hadn't figured out television yet.
That's would,
they hadn't figured out how other
people are gonna perceive them.
There was like a slow change where
people recognize bullshit and they were
allowed to do less and less of it.
And if you go back and you
watch father knows best,
here it is.
Yes ma'am.
Oh Babe.
Or I say your home.
This is me.
The tall.
How was the movie
like?
Didn't go to the movie.
Go to the movie?
No Sir.
When I wasn't supposed to.
Yes sir.
And I want to race him by school to
guarantee the other seat and I heat it.
Larry's and I was going to make
believe like I want it today,
but I couldn't.
So that's why I'm telling
you what happened.
When did you decide to tell us about it?
When I was walking the
bike home from Larry's,
it's too big for him to ride.
Glad you decided to tell us the truth.
Of course you realize
you can't keep a bicycle.
You one why'd you were being disobedient.
We're going to have to find
something to do with the bike.
Dad's,
that's a kid came clean.
Let him keep the bike dad,
the bike kind of fucking lessons.
You teach it some bullshit.
He didn't do anything illegal.
No,
I came forward and told
him what the story was.
That's the kind of stuff that the kids,
now it's,
Oh,
I'm afraid to go tell pop because
you've got to take my bike away.
That some 1957 type of psychology in 2014
I think they would say the best way to
make this go away or to make it never
happen again is a reward him with the bike
to reward him and say,
look you,
you did a good job by telling me in the
future you would benefit much more from
just doing what I tell
you in the beginning.
Don't be lying,
bitch.
Go ride your bike.
And then he thinks Dad's cool,
not dad.
Some Dick is going to take
my fucking lawfully one bike.
He won the bike.
I mean I,
that was a bad example.
Dad thought this was
going to be good stuff.
Yeah.
Well that was good.
That was a bummer man.
I love her.
I love the word.
Yeah,
it is a bummer.
Well it's,
you know,
it's 1957 logic.
They just weren't that good at TV yet.
They didn't understand.
They didn't understand how it
was coming off to other people.
Like,
we just watched that and
it looks so ridiculous,
right?
Well,
it real ad you've got that horse
which go back to isolation tanks
if Ricky time in television,
but it's,
it's indicative of this thing that I
think we're experiencing this thing that
everything is constantly improving
and one of the best ways to see that
improvement.
Like you don't,
if you want it to determine
the age of a tree,
you would chop the tree down and
he'd look at the rings of the tree.
I think if you wanted to determine the
progress of our culture in terms of like
the rings on a tree,
like in that sort of a way,
there's no better way to do it.
Then they go back and look
at the sections of our media,
go back and look at
like the $6 million man.
You know,
go back and look at the fall guy.
Go back and look at the incredible hulk.
Go back and look at,
you know,
the evolution of TV.
Yeah.
Dallas,
you know,
watch old television.
Watch the Dukes of Hazard Watch old
television shows and then go back to leave
it to beaver,
go back to this shit,
get back to this craziness that
we're watching and then realize like,
whoa,
there was like this weird
steady progression up to
x files and then you know,
game of Thrones,
like the media has improved.
Like it's a totally different organism.
The type of shows you see if you watch
a modern day episode of game of Thrones,
and there's not a film that was made in
the 1960s that could compare to that.
I don't get,
I think Stanley Kubrick was a genius.
I think 2000 West Bass Odyssey was
a marvel of of cinema for the time,
but it can't fuck with
what they have now on TV.
Hbo,
game of Thrones is one of the best
movies of all time and it's like 10 hours
every season.
It's madness.
It's 7 billion.
It was it 4 million.
What's the cost on that?
I don't know.
It's got to be expensive
as fuck her episode.
It's perfect.
It's a fuck.
It's a perfect show.
And my point being,
if you try to compare game of
Thrones to father knows best,
it's insane.
It's hard to believe it.
These are made for the same organism and
you got it occupied the same amount of
time of a person's interest.
Yes.
It's hard.
It's gotten to hold somebody's
interest and I think it's that.
I don't think it's a continual improvement
in the understanding of human beings
and I think it takes something
really intense to rattle us.
Now it takes like a true detective.
It takes like it's,
you can't just have a normal relationship
like bridges of Madison County.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Clint,
what are you doing?
Like what are you doing?
You're hanging out with this chick.
You guys are drama Queens.
You know you don't have much time left.
Why you crying?
Get out of there.
Go,
go.
Have a drink.
Get out of here.
Stop nothing.
Meanwhile you watch game of Thrones.
There's fucking dragons.
Okay?
There's this white walkers.
People were sword fighting in the middle
of the night of was white walkers.
Oh,
it's the fucking tags.
How about the giants are great.
It's a madness show.
I love the crazy shit is
happening and crazy stuff.
What the humans do to each other is
so shocking and if you tried to watch,
if you tried to watch um,
a magnum Pi after that,
you'd be like,
come on man,
it's the world's changed.
We've gotten a much deeper understanding
of what really freaks people out and we
require that to get freaked
out or today's trolls.
Today's Youtube trolls could start wars
in the 1940s if he could send those guys
back at time,
like the really sophisticated trolls,
the ones we read,
their Twitter account and you can
barely even tell if they're trolling.
They're just so,
and then you watch like some of the
arguments that get into the skies and
artists.
I don't know what that is.
Trolling is save.
Somebody wanted to reach out to,
I should probably not tell
you the trolls get mad.
Like what the fuck?
We got a fresh one.
We've got to lie on the bed.
They're not going to call me out.
It's not a call you out thing.
They would contact you
in some sort of a way.
Either insulting you and try and get you
to respond to them or mockingly in love
with you to try to get you to
respond to them and then turn on you.
Uh,
they would try to pretend that they were
outraged about certain specific issues
just to get a rise out of you.
Try to engage you in just an as a game.
There's people now that have,
there's a group of folks,
that kind of stuff.
It's a sport.
It is kind of a sport,
you know,
if you can get a good one on the line.
Yeah know,
oh my,
I haven't gotten on the line before.
It's hilarious.
Got You.
Yeah.
I get rid of it and gotten in arguments
with people before and you realize like,
what am I,
I don't even know you and you.
It takes a lot of time to realize that
because the Internet is a new thing in
the interacting with people on the
Internet is what's been around 10 years.
If I study your buttons to
say something like that,
you see what he does when you say that
the longest people were interacting on
the Internet like this,
like in this sort of like instantaneous,
like Twitter type comments
or youtube type comments.
That's never,
it hasn't been more than a decade.
This is a new thing.
It was a new thing for people.
So people who were,
uh,
who liked to get a rise out of people.
If you can't do it at work,
especially if you're stuck at a job
that sucks and you have no means of
expression of the evil inside you.
That's why I wonder why does it people
watch these videos and then say that like
with Hamilton,
they watched the video
there and then their comics.
I don't Hamilton Morris,
Hamilton Morris.
We owe him an apology.
I mean when that podcast was made,
we both got way too.
Hi Brian and I got him.
We took him to the center
of the earth this morning.
We took him to more door.
We have this weed that was grown on Pluto
and came over here in a time capsule.
I don't know where we got that shit from.
Who?
Who's was that?
I didn't remember.
I didn't even,
well you didn't have to twist.
This is where there with Hamilton
Morris who is the psychedelic.
Sure.
So we went to the bottom of the swimming
pool and fucking set up a picnic table.
I mean we went deep.
It was rough man.
I don't know what the
fuck we're talking about.
Half the time we were in a conversation,
we were like seven,
eight hits and have some insane sativa
and there was no way we should have been
having a conversation in a podcast.
No Way.
We were just,
we were wage.
You barbecued.
Uh,
I turned out okay.
It was not bad.
We interact with him
in the tank was better,
the whole thing,
you know that.
But the comments were evil.
Well,
you know,
even on some of these other
ones you read and they say,
Oh,
you know,
this or that or this guy,
they're trying to make an assumption,
you know,
an evaluation about somebody
they don't know anything about.
And the fact that you just spent your
time over viewing what it is they just did
and now you're going to be
a mean spirited about it.
Right.
Why don't you just don't do it.
Just don't look just,
you know,
but you find that I didn't know,
these are these kinds of cats
that that's what they're up to,
these trolls that they
enjoy and make an uh,
you know,
getting a rise out of people,
which is a bummer when you don't have
a lot of time to get her because you're
trying to get through life
without as little as these,
you know,
infractions as possible so you
could keep your mind in a positive,
you know,
format and then somebody saying something
mean or ugly about you and you're
reading it and you're going,
Oh shit man,
I wish that that didn't get said about me.
You know,
I think there's a benefit
to it though.
I think there's a benefit to interacting
with negative people is that you
understand that there are
negative people out there.
Cause if you,
if you don't interact with
them on a regular basis,
I don't think you'll appreciate
the positive people as much.
And I think that's just the
weird aspect of human beings.
We get accustomed to whatever,
we get accustomed to,
all sorts of things.
It seems unacceptable.
Like if you look at the things
and customs that people,
uh,
carry on in other countries,
there's certain rites of passage for
manhood that if you tried to implement
today in the United States,
like the weird shit that they do in Africa
where it circumcising each other with
sharp sticks and they have to go
crawl through thorn bushes naked,
like a bunch of crazy shit
they make these guys do.
And if you try to implement
that stuff in America today,
we would laugh at you.
But to them like this
is how they've done it.
This is how they've
done it for a long time.
And people get used to
all sorts of weird shit.
So they,
I think a lot of people have gotten
used to something that just raw,
it rages against their sensibilities
and it rages against their body,
rages against their sensibilities because
they've somehow or another committed
themselves to a safe job
that is not inspiring.
And they think that maybe if they just
waited a little while or thought about it
better,
they could have eventually figured out
how to do what they actually want to do.
And when you're wanting to someone who,
who has done that,
then you see the benefit of it
and it fucks with people's heads,
you know?
And I think there's a lot of people
that live a life of regret and bitter.
Super unfortunate.
You know?
And I think
the way our society is
structured currently,
I don't,
I don't see that changing anytime soon.
It just seems like so many people are
rushing out to enter into the workforce
because the economy is not so good.
So everybody's scrapping for jobs and
they're willing to take jobs they might
not have ordinary ordinarily taken
because they want the security of it.
It's a very trying time
for a lot of people,
but if you could figure out a
way to separate on your own,
you know,
selling coffee mugs are
fucking figuring something out,
damn,
you'll be so much better off.
Well it allows you to be more independent
and your ability to provide for
yourself.
If you could figure out
something you can do.
What I find to be a little
bit discouraging is the uh,
the lack of a interest in
manufacturing products.
And then,
um,
see,
like this country used to be,
like I say,
really have a lot of
pride and craftsmanship.
See,
we still have a talent pool here.
We have a lot of creative people.
We have a lot of uh,
you know,
intelligent people and we need to pull
these people together and get back into
manufacturing our own products here.
Yeah,
that's what I believe would
be a good thing to get kids.
They took auto shop out of the school,
I think.
I don't think that they do the
welding anymore in school wood shop.
I don't know what they do in school.
A lot of schools don't a lot school
have that anymore.
There's a lot of liability issues.
Those things to people.
I don't think it's very common.
It's not something they teach
kids how to use a hammer.
You know,
you go to school,
you should teach a kid how
to work a hammer or a saw.
Well,
I think you know,
the ebb and flow that we were talking
about with technology and that people,
some,
some folks kind of like bouncing back
the other way and looking towards
mechanical things and being in
love with mechanical things.
I think that also is going to be said
about working for big companies that I
think that a lot of these people are
going to get this feeling of like,
man,
I'm just lost in this sea of people.
Whereas I can make kitchen knives.
I can make handmade kitchen knives
in my garage over the weekend,
start selling them,
and then one day or another
eventually break through.
I've got a website from Squarespace
and I put together this fucking knife
collection and now I'm selling
them online and now I'm independent
because using a Monte TV chef,
Luigi is endorsed my,
uh,
that shit you want some
handmade like does a company.
Um,
there's a couple of companies
that have sent me a crest trail,
knives,
kestrel knives and a vehement knives.
And there were companies that
did the exact same thing.
They just started making knives and start
selling them that were in tonight's,
they loved the beauty of the
construction of the NYSE VM at knife.
They made me this fucking big,
crazy,
cool thing.
It's like all the handles all handmade.
And when you,
when you know,
you see that someone can make a
living doing that and like can,
when you're chopping onions
with something like that,
are you doing something in the kitchen
or you're using it for camping or hunting
or something like that?
It's like you're feeling like you have
a piece of craftsmanship with you.
Awesome.
I love that.
Right.
What does that,
there's a connection to
the person who made it,
right?
Yeah.
Like a more obvious connection.
Absolutely.
Like if you had a handmade,
like my friend Ari went to China,
get a handmade suit,
fucking handmade.
[inaudible] perfect.
Yeah.
That's me and a guy mind,
you know,
that's,
there's something extra jazzy
about the fact that you know,
that a guy made this for you.
Like that feels good.
That's right.
He took your,
your proportions into consideration.
Yeah.
Cause you're six feet tall
doesn't mean that your,
your knees are bending here or
your stride is this or that.
And is,
he's an artisan.
I mean,
he's an artist and he
creates a beautiful suit.
It's a,
it's a pleasure out of that.
So that's back to that,
that,
that feeling of accomplishment.
W you could feel like by making stuff.
Oh,
look at,
I feel good about that.
Like what we do with the chambers,
we,
uh,
we really put a lot of effort into the
manufacturing of them and the products
that we use,
the,
the parts,
all of them.
Not that there's anything wrong with,
uh,
you know,
whatever we use no cheap parts.
There was nothing made in China.
Not that there's anything
wrong with made in China,
but we don't buy anything that's
used in China for our stuff at all.
So I'll either made here or north
in North America somewhere to,
to,
uh,
we have a few European parts
from German and Switzerland,
but the rest of it's all a,
it made here in America
because of the quality.
We insist upon getting the best pieces.
And that was the guy you spoke about,
Lilly,
John Lilly didn't invented
these chambers in the beginning.
He,
his docker 10 was a doctorate
in or whatever it is.
His,
uh,
his,
his perspective was that it was always
better to buy or to you implement or use
it,
the better quality,
uh,
piece of equipment then to create this
what it is that it is and that is,
you know,
so I agree with that so
much that the better it is,
the better it is just saying,
oh,
you can get away with it all.
We could do it this way.
It's cheaper.
Or,
you know,
a sec,
it's,
I find it,
if you could figure out
the best way to do things,
that's the way to do it.
First Class,
you've got first class or no class.
You know what I mean?
These people come up with this thing.
Oh,
it's,
this is what I used to
mix sound right on the,
I do monitors mixed us from the stage.
I don't think Susan was saying,
he said,
hell,
how has it,
is it,
oh,
it's okay.
I'm pretty good.
I said,
no,
I'm not in that.
We don't do pretty good.
We don't do okay.
We get to just the way you want.
I'm going to have that
in a second for you.
You just communicate with me and we'll
have a just exactly the way you want
that.
Not a problem.
Right.
Well that's like many aspects of life.
There's some people that are
happily halfass and things.
Yeah.
Just happily getting
to the end of the day.
Slunk over,
you know,
slumped over and just tired.
And,
and then there's other folks that
like you who were fucking crazy,
who,
uh,
figure out a way to invest in incredible
amount of time to try to renovate and
reinvigorate this,
uh,
this business that had kind
of been forgotten about.
I mean,
when you came along there was like
somebody tanks and then there was a couple
other ones that you could
kind of find online,
you know,
that were made in Europe,
Europe,
it hadn't,
it had a little bit more
popularity in Europe
Pathfinder.
And then they had,
uh,
let's see,
oasis has been around
since from the beginning.
Why was it more popular in
Europe than it wasn't American?
You know,
uh,
any idea is,
you know,
they were,
I really don't know,
to be honest with
it.
Still wasn't popular.
It's still way more popular.
Even now overseas,
like I get letters all the time from,
there's a new place that opened up
in London and I believe this one in
Manchester that opened up and I get
messages from those guys all the time.
So I know it's there are opening up new
ones so it's not like it's already there
and established.
Well that's what we were
talking about earlier.
A little bit on the way over here.
We got a chance to have a little
brief discussion about the uh,
you know,
the,
the future in the,
in the industry there I
got a chance to show you,
uh,
some of these uh,
rules and regulations
now that had been uh,
you know,
uh,
pinned up by you know,
the uh,
various health agencies,
NSF,
national sanitization foundation.
Well just explain that to people.
There's,
there's home tags and then there's
commercial tanks and you know,
people always,
when I tell them,
hey,
you should go to the float
lab and getting a tank,
they go,
wait a minute,
somebody's been in that tank before me.
That is a very good question and that
is a question that up until now has it
been like completely thoroughly
examine and your tanks.
Like when people come over my house,
one of the things they always look at it,
it's like the back of the tank
while the equipment is set up.
And they'd go,
what the fuck is all that?
And I go,
well,
that one ozone,
these ones are filters.
And like is that overkill?
I'm like,
I dunno what overkill is.
I don't know.
I'm not,
I'm not.
Uh,
I all I know is a tank is awesome.
Crash makes the best tanks.
If he says it should be like this,
then it probably should be like this.
But when you talk to people that
have other tanks that go to dot,
got like a little fucking spa pump,
I get a little spa pump that's about
the size of a basketball and that's it.
And you got like a,
a JPL fucking set up back there
with digital this and fucking porno.
More complicated.
As we get more and more involved with
the authorities like UL and UL is what
underwriters laboratory,
they do all electrical certification
for any kind of stuff like this.
These people that what had happened to
mine where mine shorted out is fairly
common.
I showed you the email too about
this and these electrical issues.
There's,
you got an email without naming anybody.
There was another manufacturer that,
uh,
makes pods and his pod
melted into oblivion.
Yeah.
He made some sort of a thing and it just,
it all fucking fell apart.
There's awesome ones out there,
but we don't want to
slink out or anything.
But for home use,
it's a different thing.
And a lot of these people are taking
these home use ones and they're using them
for these commercial places and all
these different people going in there.
And who knows if they're jerking
off some of them probably,
let's be honest.
Uh,
and where's that going?
You know,
it's like going through
your little spa filter.
That's not enough for me,
man.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
This is a video.
This is the video that Brian made.
Areas where the water is,
it doesn't,
yeah.
Well this is all the shit
that I've already said before
earlier in this podcast.
So differently.
That was before I got my nose fixed.
Why?
Underwater faces floating above the water.
But your ears are a subject.
We already said all this stuff,
but you can watch the video
and you can kind of see it.
Yeah.
My nose when I got my nose opened up,
changed my voice a little bit.
That's crazy.
I can breathe out of my nose now.
Yay for almost all my life,
dude.
I had no nose.
My nose was a useless piece of shit.
It was just bad Cartlidge
scar tissue in there.
But now,
now I can smell when Brian's
been smoking cigarettes today.
Busted.
Smell him a mile away.
This motherfucker.
Um,
so that is,
that's the tank from,
what is a video from Brian?
This is a wow,
it's a good question.
I would say in a while
cause thousand nine maybe.
Is it really the reason I
think it's been more than that.
Maybe.
I don't know if I said,
here's this was tank number one facing.
Yeah.
This is another,
uh,
see where like 12 steps from that.
You know,
Joe is a,
we've wanted to get over and switch it
out for him because he's a deserves to
have a more updated version.
He was okay with everything
but well craft against you.
Okay.
Is that good?
You know,
I don't want to hear,
okay,
well that's not okay with me.
Even if it's okay with you.
Still not okay with me.
And so that we were so
happy to be able to uh,
you know,
get you up to speed.
We still have some steps
to go for you though to,
we'd like to,
what are the steps?
Well,
you know,
this is the,
uh,
previous version now of what we have,
you know,
so as time goes by,
well,
the one I have now is even bigger
than the one that's in that video.
The one I have now is this
weird fucking meat locker.
Beautiful.
We're working on it today.
Feet tall and,
and salt.
And that means more than seven feet tall.
And I don't know how many feet wide
was he?
Six,
six,
seven and eight,
I think is what it is.
And that's a,
that's a great chamber there.
It's a good,
as you're using it,
see people,
that's the first thing that it,
it,
you know,
Oh,
I joined the gym.
You know what,
what does that,
you've got to go to the gym,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Get up membership.
Whoa,
whoa.
You know,
somebody,
some of these things sit in their
house and they don't use it.
You know,
what is it
people need?
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard.
But people need something to like
jolt them out of their normal everyday
routine.
They need something to jolt them
to get an old Dell try one day.
Like today I'm going to go to the gym
and they work out in the next day.
It's like fat,
fuck it.
They just,
for whatever reason,
it didn't catch fire,
but they want to improve,
you know,
and that's the first step.
But the,
uh,
the,
the actually doing things,
people have a lot of folks,
they discuss a lot of stuff.
They read about other people,
all these things.
And instead of like,
actually I sit down and say,
okay,
to what can I actually do today to get
to make me do something that is of a
value,
you know,
rather than,
these are the criticizing of
other people is a really uh,
you know,
it doesn't really help so much,
and well it's fun though.
It's fun.
I love to do it,
you know,
as a criticizing of other people's
oftentimes a good sense of a,
a source of the entertainments
and output to all right man.
I can't,
you know,
you have to be careful of criticizing
too much or getting only into the vein of
criticism.
Like you're consistently constantly like
people that are smart can oftentimes
make poor choices or dumb choices.
And I think one of the,
the dumb choices that a lot of smart
people make is to like consistently and
constantly look for the negative and
things consistently and constantly.
There's a lot of things you can focus on.
The negatives of things
are always going to exist.
You're not stupid,
you see them,
but to constantly and consistently like
only rally against dumb things in pop
culture over and over again.
At a certain point in time
I have to go listen what,
you know,
we see it,
we see it too.
Like what do you,
you're just angry about it.
Like that doesn't,
that doesn't help anybody.
Like what is either is either be funny
or shut the fuck up because we see it's
dumped too and it's not,
you know,
the funny part is best if someone instead
of Joe sort of added to the good part
of our culture,
you know,
added,
may come up with something
that's entertaining,
come up with something
that taps into what,
uh,
people would,
like to be getting here.
There's more than this
one if that one's empty.
Oh No.
Right.
I Dunno.
Either way.
Thank you my friend.
You're welcome.
I just think one of the things
is the tank provides is a,
this sort of introspective moment that
I think a lot of folks are missing.
You know,
and sometimes people get caught in
patterns and you can get caught up in a
pattern of negativity.
You can get caught up in
a pattern of depression.
You can get caught up
in a pattern of regret.
You can get caught up in
a pattern of friendships,
of,
of kindness.
You can get caught up in
a pattern of affection.
You can,
you can get into good patterns too.
You just have to reject the
bad ones when they come along.
Don't indulge.
It'd be ready for those.
You can just make sure that that's where
the chamber self aware going there and
you got to look at yourself.
I mean,
when I first started doing it,
I got an eye.
I didn't even know what
it was or whatever,
but I would be in for an hour every day.
I would go in there and it's beat
myself up because I was a damaged goods,
you know,
crash.
I'm not buying it.
Yeah.
Once upon a time on a sir.
Oh,
well,
I,
I would anyway.
But getting in there every day for me
for one hour in the beginning and see,
I didn't even know what it was,
but I knew that that's what it was.
I put,
so I'm in there and I beat myself up.
I'd come out of there,
I'd be like beaten up
and I'd get out and go,
wow.
I feel pretty good.
I could sit down and they used
to have a pa out there at that.
It wasn't a ranch.
I had a renter then in a
big screen and everything.
But I would come in there and I always
need people around me and stimulation and
stuff.
But I get out of that chamber.
I come in to all by myself and sit down
and not turn nothing on and just sit
there and feel actually
relax without use of drugs.
You know,
I'm reliant on,
you know,
certain things.
In the past too.
It made me feel different ways,
you know,
but the chamber now it,
it was able to,
uh,
affect the way I felt as a matter of
factly without the use of any kind of,
uh,
additives.
And when I learned about that,
that that's quite a,
that's quite an impressive,
that a game changer.
You know,
you,
you now have a window into yourself,
you can now go in and look at you
and see what that is and then say,
hey woo,
look at that with that is over.
Same thing because you're aware
of what you are and who you are,
what did you did and where you've
been and what not like that.
But you have to be willing to,
you know,
admit to all that surrender,
whatever.
And then you pick yourself up and start
to use what it is that you're able to
figure out about what to do from here.
Exactly.
And stand by it and then compromise.
And the tank tells you that
like give me the experience,
sort of introduces you to yourself and
there you are in this box and you realize
there's two parts of me,
there's this thing inside of me that
that apparently has better information.
And then there's this thing outside that
wants to get high or it goes to go see
chicks or do whatever
you're going to want to do.
He said go out and blah blah blah.
You eat too much.
People do different things,
you know,
and the gamble,
gambling,
this is all kinds of stuff and
cigarettes and we get a hit from that,
you know,
the,
you know and it,
but the effect that these things have,
see what they do is you also,
they will alter your perspective
of yourself sometimes have these,
these studies,
how people are drunk and they're all like,
ah,
la La,
la,
La,
you know,
and they're really,
it kind of gives them an impression
that they're more happy to be around or
something.
The drunker they get the
stupid or they seem to be,
but they don't seem to evaluate
themselves from that perspective.
They think they're more fun or something.
Yeah.
Self evaluation is one of
the hardest things to do.
Right.
It's the one of the hardest
things for a person to do to,
to step away from their,
whatever inaccuracies they've been
telling themselves to make themselves feel
better about their life
or their situation.
And then to force yourself to go,
you know,
this is,
this is not right.
This is this,
this society
has an influence on you as well.
Cause you don't want to look too,
like you're saying,
you know,
I can remember certainly
want to get into this.
They start talking about
certain things and people go,
oh,
you know,
I said I don't want to talk
about that or anything like that.
So you got to have a,
it's good to work on yourself.
This,
I'm big on this selfish Chisholm.
I think of it
saying though about people not
wanting to talk about certain things.
Like what kind of things?
Well,
a conspiracy theories.
Yeah,
stuff like that.
You know,
I kind of a negative
thing because when I was,
you know,
in Vegas,
the same place and the
guy loading is showing,
right?
And the truck driver goes,
oh,
there's the Kim planes.
I go,
what?
He goes,
hey,
look at that.
And I go,
oh my God,
I couldn't believe it.
There's airplanes spraying this magazine.
Unbelievable.
So I was damaged goods from that.
That messed me up for years.
And he said he quit telling people
about it because they're on the,
he's driving a truck and go,
oh yeah,
I take another hit on the crack pipe.
Meanwhile,
there it is right in front of you.
He should stop telling people about it
and you should just go on Google and find
out what it actually is.
There was nothing.
This is like 15 years ago.
Well,
it's not chem trails seat.
This is where people are really confused.
It's just airplanes create artificial
clouds and hazy environments.
If an airplane is going through the
atmosphere and there's a certain amount of
condensation,
it creates an artificial cloud.
It just does the jet engine that you
mean you should look into this more than
anybody because you've talked to me
about this before and I know that you
probably have these ideas in your head,
um,
about the government
spraying things in the sky.
Say I'm sure whoever it is,
airplanes.
Someone may have done that
at some point in time.
Most likely has done
that some point in time,
but that's not what you're saying.
What are you seeing those
clouds that go across,
those are actual clouds,
clouds that be made by jet engine.
It's like this has all been proven.
This is all scientific
that everyone agrees on it.
It's not,
there's no controversy about this at all
when it comes to people who understand
jet propellant engines or jet engines
and airplanes and airplanes and an
atmosphere conditions like there's been
articles about this since the 1980s I
mean this,
all it is is in in 2001 when
September 11th happened,
there was a,
an article that was on cnn.com like a
couple of days afterwards that was talking
about the changes in the
temperature because there
weren't the artificial clouds
that were used to having overhead on a
daily that are created when planes fly
through the atmosphere.
So it's not something that they
were being like secretive about.
This is just an effect of airplanes.
The real camp trail,
it was one of the things that I said on
my television show when we covered this.
They're burning jet fuel in the sky.
That's the real chem trail.
You're,
we're polluting the sky and we just
love it because we can get across the
country in in five hours and that's
where guys like Elon Musk and these
geniuses,
they want to create these
incredible high speed trains.
That's what these guys are so amazing
because if they can figure out how to do
that and use the same sort of
technology that keeps Google cars safe,
and if everybody can work
together and make these,
we might be able to
change the environment.
Like the amount of jet fuel that we burn.
It's like thousands and
thousands of flights every hour,
all across the country,
constantly going back and forth.
Rocket ships apparently take a
lot of a propulsion to get out.
There's a credible amount of rocket ships.
I talked to him and they,
uh,
they say,
oh yeah,
the,
the biggest thing is the pollution that's
created when these things blast off
the amount of,
uh,
whatever it goes into the horse fair.
But look,
you see fire,
yeah.
Fire.
Unless something that's
not good is on fire,
you know,
fires coming out of a metal tube.
That's never good.
It's never,
what's good now is that people have that
opportunity to investigate information.
That's why right now I think that,
uh,
you know,
ignorance and a negligence
or sort of the same thing.
They're like,
people say,
oh,
I didn't know what you didn't know because
you didn't care enough to look into
it.
And that is true
times you get caught in a
situation where you don't,
you know,
you just still don't understand
even after all the facts are uh,
well you,
you also have contrary
opinions back and forth.
There's this legitimate are varied,
especially when it comes to
like certain historical events.
Like there's a lot of people
that wanted to talk about,
like JFK is a good example.
It's a lot of people that love talking
about conspiracies and electric wrap that
went up tight.
And when you have these conversations
with them and you look at the,
the contrary evidence on both sides,
pro and con,
it's like,
wow,
there's a lot of like massive amounts of
confusion as to what the actual events
where.
But actually so many people wanted him,
dad,
that you can't even pit the pit.
You couldn't pin the tail on
that donkey no matter what.
Yeah,
there was multiple people that
were upset with his actions.
Why would they be so lucky
if it was just a lone nut?
Yeah.
Would they be so lucky?
All those other people would be so happy.
So lucky because then the situation when
you have perpetuated to this point now,
if it was a lone nut back then in the
system was actually fail safe from
situations like this.
I think what the,
the knife 1960s
and the death of Kennedy and you know
the Kent state shootings and all that
stuff.
I mean as tragic as it is
for then and for those times,
I think that ultimately that kind of
stuff is sort of a reminder and a lot of
ways to the people of today about how
bad it can get if things get out of hand.
So when he stays start creeping
up on these infringements,
on civil liberties like
and people start rising up,
that's where you see things like
us going to Syria gets shot down.
I mean you see the entire country,
both Republicans.
That was the first time that ever happened
where they had made a plan to go in
and invade something and they did not
do it because of the voice of the,
of the public,
the voice of the whole public.
You know?
It's like how many Osca Publicans
at this point in time retire.
I don't care if you've got
a blue suit and green suit.
A per bastard please.
Thank you.
Broke and we're not
invading other countries.
What for what exactly?
We're not fixing the problems
that we have at home.
How about the fact there's no water?
How about the fact that Texas,
it hasn't rained in
Texas and fucking years.
You know California had like one rainfall
like over the past like three or four
months.
It's terrible.
I mean that's something to consider
this something to think about.
Where the fuck we're going to get
our water from desalination plants.
Maybe drain out that
fucking goofy ocean tire.
Those fish sucking up all the good water.
What's happening with the fish
all dead off over there too.
Everywhere.
What's going on?
That's a lot of times deal.
Um,
a side effect of pollution to um,
or it could be a side effect of um,
certain types of um,
like fish need a certain oxygen level
and things can happen and they developed
dead zones and the water and there's no
oxygen and all the fish just drowned.
You've seen that on the zillions of them.
Hundreds of thousands here.
There we looked all over the world.
It seems like there's
problems but it could be just,
you know,
whatever.
I don't know.
Well I think it's always happened but it
happens certainly because of pollution
as well.
I believe pollution is bad.
Don't need to say,
oh look,
it's okay cause it's only
this amount or we can,
we got to,
we got to camp.
We're containing it.
See this is the containment system.
See what do they do with that stuff?
Stuff in the ground from
waiting for Godzilla coming
at all about we're going to
collect this garbage and then
planted in the ground over here.
Well that's what a little kid does.
You know when you're sweeping up you just,
it's a cartoon.
You pick up the carpet and you
sweep it under the carpet pot,
that carpet down number,
no shit.
You know?
Yeah,
it's a very childish way,
but it's also the people that were
alive that implemented these systems.
I mean they're not alive
anymore and they were,
when they were our age,
it was a completely different era.
And then when you go
back to look at their,
you know,
the distance between us and the
1940s go back and look at the,
the 1940s and the distance between them
and the same amount of time and you're
in the 18 hundreds.
Okay.
You're in the like the times where
people were riding horses and they had a
paint their pictures.
That's,
that's how much distance has traveled.
I mean,
we really,
if you go back to 1940 and you look at
those guys that are running the space
program or work with those guys who
were involved in nuclear program,
how old were they?
They in their forties let's
say they're in their forties.
Let's say that,
uh,
they were born in the year 1900 and
they were designing and working on all
these,
these crazy technological innovations
from the time if you went back from them
too,
as far as us looking at the 1940s,
you would be,
what,
60,
74 years go to 74 years before that.
So 74 years before that is 18 fucking 26.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
They got a horse that
stop and think about that.
They're 1940 like world to us.
Like when we consider the 1940 world
is the early 18 hundreds to them.
Huh?
It's essentially two
decades or 2 cents on the,
uh,
just the,
you know,
the regular ratio.
When you start to consider that,
you know,
the exponential type
situation and other growth is
magnified as it goes on.
It continues to expand itself out.
No doubt.
I mean,
the growth and change between 1820 and
1940 was nothing compared to 19 four d to
2010.
I mean,
it's just this,
this is madness.
They didn't look ahead and you say,
oh boy.
Yeah,
I know it's going to be really weird,
but it's just so strange that we're
still running on the momentum of these
people's ideas as far as like
storage of nuclear weapon,
storage of nuclear waste,
reset,
but fascinating though real kids in.
I agree wholeheartedly,
but also as a person who's not involved
in creating nuclear technology and
they're not involved in any of that.
I find it fascinating just as an observer,
like looking at it all like,
wow,
this is really an interesting scenario
because it was created by these
incredible geniuses that lived as
long ago as 1820 something to them.
I mean,
that is really hard to believe.
It's really hard to believe.
It's hard to believe is that we're
still operating on that same mechanism.
Exactly.
It's really hard to believe and it's,
it's hard to believe that we
still have like garbage dumps.
We have like dumps,
right dumps.
We'd take all the garbage,
we throw it over there
and then those dumps,
he started fucking disasters.
We went to a garbage dump.
Who Film something for the man showed
a garbage dump wants it was well,
it was horrible.
Well this is a horrible fucking,
they dig a hole and dumped the
throw all the shit there and stay,
just keep digging holes.
It fucking stinks dude.
They just cover it up with
dirt and it's disgusting.
It doesn't,
uh,
like the uh,
fume,
the methane or whatever,
uh,
build up if you put it under the ground.
That's a good question.
I don't know.
I Dunno.
I mean methane comes
from biological weights.
Doesn't want us that this guy took a,
a rat or a mouse and he,
uh,
made an art thing and he
covered up the mouse with the,
uh,
with the resin.
Right.
And then the mouse was the running
through the resident apparently until it,
it couldn't go into a further.
Right.
He was like stuck in the resident,
the mouse.
But that's an art piece.
That's an asshole is an asshole.
He glued a mouse.
So it's inside of this thing now.
And then there were in that
one day that was up on the,
uh,
it exploded.
That was like made out of a plastic
glass stuff and it exploded from the gap
that the mouse was offgassing from inside
of it and the mouse created so much
gas.
It blew this whole thing
up all over the place.
The guy told me,
whoa,
from the mouse being stuck in there,
the gas,
that
it was a offgassing as it died,
you know,
you know the smell you smell.
He said the house smelled like
that to w was you there for that?
I forget who was telling me no,
but somebody would come in and do the
mop down on the house and everything,
but that seems like an
unnecessary experiment.
You've got to remember that next time,
messing around with some mice.
Don't stick them in some plastic,
you know that they don't do well.
No.
Well there's plastics that they
can make from plant material.
Something a lot of people aren't aware of.
You can make plastic from hemp.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a biodegradable plastic
you can make from hemp.
That's for drew made a whole car ride.
Ford made a,
the first car.
The offenders who made at a Hampton,
you could hit it with a hammer.
Hemp as a weirdest plan ever.
You know,
I'm not,
I know I sound like a hippie when I
started talking great about marijuana.
But forget about marijuana.
The psychoactive benefits of marijuana.
I've gone too in depth.
I think there's,
there's a real benefit to people and I,
you know,
I hear people saying,
Oh,
you know,
kids and what about the kids?
What about the kids?
What about the kids with fucking anything?
Kids can die from aspirin.
Kids can die if they have a
contest to see who eats more salt.
Kids can die doing a lot of fucking shit.
You know,
it's not about kids,
it's about responsible use of adults.
If it's your kid,
you have a obligation to
educate your children.
Do the best you can to protect them
from the dangers of this world.
All drugs are a part of that,
including hundreds of legal ones that are
available right now that can kill your
children.
So that's not the issue.
Marijuana is a minor,
minor,
minor issue when it comes
to health and safety.
It's a major issue when it
comes to consciousness and
maybe even more so when it
comes to the implementation
of hemp as a commodity.
Hemp for paper,
hemp for building materials,
hemp for automobile panels that
are lighter and more durable.
Henry Ford figured that shit out at the
turn of the 19th or the 20th century.
I mean,
he,
he was doing that in
the early 19 hundreds.
This guy had figured that out.
The pants they make out of it and shirts
and everything and they're durable.
They're way more durable than cotton.
And now that also has one
of the best root system.
So they,
with it did to do with,
what would it be good idea to do is
where you have these erosion problems.
If they plant weed in there,
the,
uh,
the rooting system hamper.
You got to see him.
He got to see him.
When I say we,
they think you're helping.
You want to get high.
Oh,
you know,
that's just that.
Just get in your own safety of your house,
this other stuff you could
put outside and let it grow.
Hemp is a very strange plan.
There's really no,
no,
no plant like it on earth and
it's incredibly hard and dense,
but very light is what seeds they make
that that Omega three to Omega six that
well the protein to hemp protein is the
most easily digestible protein and we
sell it at a on it,
we sell a a hemp protein supplement.
We bought the best hemp you can get.
It's really fine.
It's very high in proteins
to the most expensive,
but it's the best and a lot of
people don't like the taste,
think it tastes delicious.
But
I was fixing it up with coconut water.
I uh,
I just throw a banana,
coconut water and hemp force into
a blender and that's how I do it.
Yeah,
you're off to the races.
He tug just easy.
The thing about like,
I like a lot of different protein powders,
but I feel like the vegetable proteins,
I like pea protein.
There's a Vega that is a,
I think it's an all vegan
based protein powder,
all plant based protein
powder that I like to,
I liked that.
I liked those because
they digest very easily.
You're getting the impact from it.
Yeah,
I think it's also,
it's very easy on the body,
whereas I feel like whey protein,
which is also very effective,
but it's made from you know,
way which is made from milk products.
It's,
it doesn't,
that doesn't quite digest
as easily feel it feel like,
makes my farts stink here too.
They have to keep side so
that everybody's happy.
My body has no problem with digesting it,
you know?
And it's illegal to grow
in America from Canada.
Unbelievable.
So stupid.
When I was a kid,
I used to say,
I'm going to say my mom is it?
What is wrong with this stuff?
And she said,
oh well it's all legal and that was
the best they could come up with.
That's not even,
well that doesn't even work with
hemp because hemp can't get you high.
It's just the point I was worried
about the other part growing,
but growing hemp is like
growing pine trees was like,
what if someone came along and said
he can't show growth pine trees,
no more pine trees.
You can't make pine tables.
He can't make pine bed stands,
no more pine.
You'd be like,
what are you talking about?
I can't grow pine or rose fucking
crazy girl rose bushes stuff out.
But the preposterousness of pine is
a good one because it's so readily
available.
Well,
if marijuana was legal,
it could be as readily
available as pine trees.
The shit grows everywhere.
If fucking grows everywhere,
and for the past hundred years almost,
there's been this ridiculous
boycott on this magical plant.
It's a magical plant.
If it didn't exist and someone told
you about it from another planet,
we would be sending
spaceships out to get it.
If there was,
if we found that there was pot growing
on the moon and they found if the,
if the astronauts went to the moon and
they came back with a plan and over the
next decade they analyze this plan and
found it to have a million different uses
psychoactively medically to treat PTSD,
interocular pressure from fucking glaucoma
to give people their appetite back
where they're going through chemo.
They go,
you go through a laundry list of
benefits at this fucking alien plant.
Had they had do that fucking,
what's that Virgin Guy,
Richard Branson.
He's to be sent in space ships
out to the moon with farmers.
They'd have Mexicans in space flying to
the moon to harvest the marijuana and
bring it back home.
That's where we got along here.
Yeah.
And we got an ear and these kinds
of trying to keep it illegal.
Amazing dummies like that.
Chris Christie dummy.
I don't understand it.
It well,
I understand.
I don't dummies.
They re they rail against it.
They railed,
they rallied,
they scream,
cry corporate guys.
That what we need to do is
have them on the right side.
So you need to get high.
They need to just chill down and say,
listen,
Hey,
okay,
we're going to do it.
We can do to make things better.
Yes.
And get on board.
And then people said,
hey,
and the best ways for you to get high,
you got to grab them.
Yeah.
Or sell that stuff.
Don't grab a cat.
Say,
listen,
we use it in our product now we use this
stuff because we found it's better than
what we used to use.
Well,
I think there's a lot of things
that could be done to make people,
uh,
overall just overall in this country.
Just a wee bit healthier,
just a little bit of a change in the
dial and the direction that we're all
going.
I can remember an Anthony Robbins who a,
although I've made fun of a inspirational
guys I think is actually a very
inspirational guy.
Um,
I think Anthony robins has some really
good advice and I've read a bunch of
different things that he said.
And back when I was competing
and my martial arts days,
I actually benefited very
much from a lot of his,
he had audio books I listened to by the
pool when I listened to live in a shitty
apartment.
And um,
one of the things that he said was that
if you would take into consideration
like two cars that are a,
going in a certain direction,
if one of them just has a very
slight variation off the line,
just a slight over the course of time,
the distance that it goes
from the original direction
it was going to is vast.
It's just a small change.
Just a small adjustment.
And I think that could be said,
not just of cars that are
driving parallel to each other,
but if a culture,
and I think that if something like
the tank came along and the tank in
conjunction with this new found
refusal to accept the marijuana laws,
there's a new found refusal.
And now Colorado,
there was a,
um,
an article that was written that came
out today and I think it came out today.
I found out about it today.
I retweeted it today from a reset me,
which is our friend amber lions website.
And essentially it's,
it's talking about how Colorado has made
more money and had less crime and the
tax is six months.
Read about the school.
They gave him point 9 billion or
something for the school system.
The woman who wrote it,
or her name is Laura Pedrum and uh,
yeah,
it came out on the 27th.
So days answers school.
Yeah.
Can you imagine that they're
doing something on the
planet that's putting money
into schools and it's this
and it's empowering people
start their own business.
The right people,
people who are into weed,
they're going to start their
own businesses and get rich.
That'd be a weird thing when we'd,
farmers are like a bunch of rich
people running around funding schools.
We'd farmers are paying for the
police to have better facilities.
We'd farmers are paying for the fire
department to be better equipped.
We'd farmers are paying for the
teachers to make more money.
Like this is all,
it's not just a pipe dream.
This is all a very possibility with
the community and the officials in the
community to create a situation.
These guys could be major
influences on the entire,
not only this part,
right in the podcast.
People that are listening who are not
into wheat or like I'm fucking hanging up.
This stuffs are funneling.
Indoctrination.
Yeah.
Well even if you don't want to smoke weed,
how could you ever say that
$100 million in cash revenue,
$100 million is not a great thing
that you get that kind of taxes from your
first year and who knows where this is
going to go can easily
double by the second year.
So then you got $200
million in tax revenue.
Oh my goodness.
They focus where?
When,
how much of the tax that you paid
last month went to the school system?
Who knows?
How much did the school get to Colorado?
Colorado is not that big.
No,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's big,
but it's not like the amount
of people as California,
right.
Not even close.
So you spread that money out.
If you've got,
you had to,
oh,
also there's an 800 kids and
they made $1,000 or whatever.
Do you know how much money marijuana
would make in California if they just sent
it loose to set it loose?
Just unleashed it fully legal.
Let's go.
I mean,
just the,
the medical industry here is so gigantic
that there's businesses were doctors
just give people we'd prescriptions.
It's all they do.
That's all they do.
They have a line of people
with headaches out the door.
It's,
that's their business.
Everybody's paying 40 bucks
and they're keeping it moving.
And that's legal.
I mean it's,
what they've done legally is crazy.
If they made it fully legal.
If they just said release the hounds,
it would change the culture.
It really would and it would.
It would help.
A lot of people would help a lot
of people that are resisting it.
It would help a lot of athletes and
the big one that would help a lot of
athletes is edible.
Edible marijuana for inflammation,
for injuries,
for relaxation,
for stretching just for your body.
Just forget about the psychoactive
effects of introspection and self analysis
and all that other stuff that
comes with the eating it,
the really the physical benefits,
so it'd be pretty substantial
nutritional benefits.
There's the nutrition.
You already talked about that.
I can eat it.
It's really good for that.
Super Healthy,
great for your skin.
Hemp oil is good for your skin.
You can cook with it.
It's crazy.
It's just so much more with it.
Run a car on it.
You could run a car,
you get burned.
Hemp oil.
The whole thing is so ridiculous that if
you looked at it on paper and it wasn't
the same,
hey,
we have this stuff.
We just figured it out today.
It's called a slippery a
whatever and we have it.
What would be the great,
it'll be a great plot for a book if there
was a company that somehow or another
managed to plot against one of the
most beneficial plants on earth and
suppressed the the development and use
of it for almost a century if that,
if that was a book you would
like be captivated by this plot,
like could this happen cause this possible
the one of the most beneficial plants
ever known demand could be stifled.
They might've known about it in
the beginning and then cut it off.
Like I said,
oh this stuff could catch on.
I think that what happens is one of the
things that happens is when anything is
illegal and then you start
arresting people for that thing.
You make a business and I'm
You make a business out of
that thing being illegal.
And then like we were
talking about before,
when those guys are out of a job,
like they're just out of a job.
So they'll fight to
keep their fucking job.
And one of the best ways to keep your
jobs to keep more things illegal.
If you're a guy who
arrest people for Shit,
you want to make sure
that more like marijuana
stay illegal because especially the DEA,
what would they get do if
marijuana became legal?
And then people would start to have to
have to start considering all sorts of
other drugs becoming legal as well.
Maybe they could figure
out how to direct like the,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
business aspects of it just ready to
take this money now and we'll have a,
a,
uh,
an agency,
let's say that,
uh,
works directly with
these people that then,
you know,
maybe then they could have a place and,
and being helpful,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
obviously folks,
we're not,
this is not something that
we thought on an advanced.
We're trying to work
this shit out on the fly.
Yeah.
This is not the best way
to design a government,
but it might be better than
what's already in place.
You know what's already in place.
It's just fucking silly.
You can't tell people they can't have,
we'd stop it.
You can't,
you can't tell if they're very nice to,
to involve yourself in other
people's business like that.
They're not involved in yours,
especially if you're ignorant.
You know,
I,
when I was first starting
to work for the UFC,
I would often encounter these articles
that were written that were critical of
mixed martial arts and I could tell by
reading the article that the person who
was writing it had no idea
what they were talking about.
They didn't understand the sport.
Like from a fundamental level,
they were incorrect about the rules.
They were incorrect
about what was allowed.
They were incorrect about the size of
the participants that they were one size
against eat all,
you know,
they didn't know they were there.
They were acting on really old
information and really bad information.
But yet here they are writing for some
loving an opinion in writing it in a
published form where they
spreading it out to the world.
That's what they're doing when
it comes to psycho appreciation.
It's like having a guy do a wine,
a wine review.
This never had any wine.
Yeah.
Well I'll,
I'll do you one better.
Anybody that is trying to get anything
like marijuana or mushrooms or any of
these things removed from the culture
and has no experience in them whatsoever.
It's like a guy who's never had
sex trying to make sex illegal.
It's mean.
It's,
well,
it's insane.
It's insane that anybody allows it.
If someone who has never had sex before
tried to make sex illegal to all of us
that enjoy sex,
he'd be like,
are you crazy?
It's like one of my favorite things,
like why would you cut the sex out?
Because I don't get sex
so you don't get sex.
I don't like it.
I don't appreciate it.
It rots your brain.
We can journeys and someone could just
somehow or another trick people and did
not having sex.
Obviously sex is a natural urge.
Marijuana is something
that you learn about,
but they're both beneficial and enjoyable
aspects of this beautiful thing called
life and for whatever fucking reason,
we've allowed these dummies that are
obviously like you look at a guy like Newt
Gingrich.
Dude,
you don't,
you don't get to tell me anything.
You don't get to tell me what
to do or how to live at all.
You don't get to,
I don't believe in you.
You know I think your corporate puppet
and you don't get to tell me that pot's
bad.
When I look at Chris Christie,
you're 300
pounds.
You don't get to give advice.
Oh,
marijuana rots the brain and this.
What about your fucking brain?
It's allowed you to balloon
up like an other animal.
You don't even look like a human.
You look like some sloths,
some some walrus type creature that's
waddled out of the ocean and put on big
pants.
You're ridiculous person.
You can't talk about marijuana.
You don't experience it.
If you don't experience
it on a regular basis,
you don't know what the
fuck you're talking about.
And that's the problem that
we have in our culture.
We have these people that are giving
advice on something that they have no
experience.
Other countries we're over at
mixed up and other civilizations.
These people,
they are operating for thousands
or hundreds or whatever it is.
Exactly,
and we're going to come over and say,
hey,
here we are.
Now we're going to tell you guys,
watch it.
We need humility from
people that are leading.
That's a very important thing.
So when someone takes a big strong
stance on something that they don't have
experience with or they don't
have full knowledge of like this,
he was talking about some study
that they've come out with it.
Marijuana affects the brain.
Yeah,
it affects the brain,
but they don't know if it's good or bad.
Did you read that part of it?
They don't understand
what the effects are,
what the negative effects are,
but here's other than
short term memory loss,
no one's demonstrated anything really bad,
but a lot of positive shit,
tumor shrinkage,
all sorts of medical benefits to do with
deal with inflammation and relieving of
pressure.
And for a lot of people it's good
you guys still held up on your,
I hate that.
I forget it.
It's over.
Let it go.
Short memory.
I like that.
I got some good details there later.
They come up with me when I need them.
But uh,
it's just,
it's a carry garbage around
in your head all day.
Father knows best shit is what it is.
I mean,
we're watching leave it to beaver.
We just watching a,
a less,
less like ridiculous form of it.
It's a more modern person,
incorrect moral value on you.
They've decided what is right and what's
wrong without having enough information
to even have a valid perspective with
the gall of a man to say that another man
should not be able to legally buy
something as innocuous as marijuana is.
So enraging who the fuck are,
you can't smoke a joint
somewhere by herself.
Especially a person who
placates themselves.
Obviously you're not,
you're,
you're not some militant fucking like the,
the,
the gunny and full metal jacket placate,
I don't know that word.
Uh,
you know,
what's the best way to describe placate,
like,
uh,
to make someone believe it.
Pretend like you're that way.
No,
to try to here,
I'll give you a pro to
make someone less angry.
I think it's based on placid
to try to calm me down.
Right,
right,
right.
Sorry,
I just lost my train of thought.
I'm sorry.
I have a limited vocabulary in
certain areas that you don't though.
You,
you have a very high
technological vocabulary.
I like to ask questions.
So now I have that word
in my repertoire as well.
So placate,
placate the masses.
You know that expression,
you've heard the expression a calm,
that acid.
I think I've heard the
word never understood.
What was I saying now?
What was I saying about
the people in the Oh,
that he placates his body.
He con he obviously he
gives into his urges.
In order to,
in order to be that big,
you have to be indulgent.
I mean there's no way.
So he's got issues.
So anybody that's got like some
obvious issue like that like,
man,
you're not allowed to dictate health.
And,
and,
and like consumption policy theory yeah.
Is Poor.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
It's control on yourself.
It's also against the current data.
Like there's,
there's,
there's no like real consensus that
shows any sort of significant dangers
involved in the consumption of that plant.
Certainly not like some of these other
ones that have how many dead this year
from.
But you know why those
other ones are fine too.
I don't have a problem
either being around,
but aspirin will fuck you up.
You get crazy with it.
You know,
you're your own,
uh,
your own architect.
You know,
a lot of people die
every year from aspirin.
Aspirin kills people.
You know,
nobody wants to think about that.
But people can die from
a lot of dumb shit.
That doesn't make any sense.
It's available everywhere.
It's not w our issue is
education and honesty.
And if you're not honest about
something as innocuous as marijuana,
then why am I going to trust
you about anything else?
Like what?
Where's the dangerous shit?
No.
W Oh,
we're,
we're keeping that legal
because it's always been legal.
Well,
I'm not saying you
should make that illegal,
but you got to let the less dangerous
shit into this is what if the less
dangerous shit changes the
way people look at everything,
including the dangerous shit.
Right.
And that's,
that's a real possibility that psychedelic
software have to a lot of people that
are addicted to diseases.
A lot of people that have PTSD,
they're addicted to diseases,
have had extreme benefits
from psychedelics.
There's legal crash,
you know?
Uh,
see,
that's what,
like I told us in the beginning,
this was my mom,
he said,
oh,
so what does that mean?
Now I don't even understand what that is.
I'm ranting too much.
I get,
I just get upset and I apologize
anybody's heard this before,
but,
uh,
I,
I can't help it.
At certain point in time it hits
me and I'm so confused by it.
I feel like I need to
repeat it because it's so,
it's sucks.
It's the worst part of where we're at.
It's a bottleneck.
It's one of the worst parts is this lack
of understanding about what should and
shouldn't be happening to us.
Whether it's our government committing
to wars or whether it's the people's
emails being spied upon or whether
it's people being forced to not consume
certain things that would offer different
perspectives or people being morality.
Yeah.
People,
people telling you what you can and
can't do that's not hurting anybody else.
And I think one of the things that
I'm attracted to is altering the,
the current way that I think and altering
the current way that other people
think and giving you a perspective of,
of the paths that we just get on.
We get stuck in these fucking grooves and
it's so easy to keep making those same
terms over and over again whenever you
hit these very similar moments in your
life.
And that's where something like
the isolation tank is so good.
It's so good to just
get out of that groove.
You know?
I think,
you know,
like a log.
It's even when I met you
and everything like that.
You know,
I think I went to,
I don't know if I'd just gotten back
from Costa Rica or somebody might say,
I thought,
you know,
this isn't ever going to happen.
It's just people are never
going to get with this.
And then because it was just,
you kept trying and now,
but now it seems as if these people in
general have gotten up to a place where
they're more willing to uh,
experience themselves and then,
uh,
make action on that.
Yeah,
I think,
um,
I think we're,
people are waking up with a lot things.
I mean you were talking about
earlier about pilates and yoga.
I think people are just
waking up about their body.
People were really concerned about
where their food's coming from.
Now this is something that hadn't
really existed decades ago.
No one was concerned about
organics or you know,
when one was current,
concerned about GMOs products in general.
Is this the fact that I don't,
and I'm not necessarily saying that Gmos
were all bad because I don't think they
are.
Um,
I think there's definitely
some benefits to,
uh,
to some genetically modified organisms.
But I think it's important that we have
the conversations that people who are
really intelligent start dedicating time
and effort to researching the benefits,
pros and cons,
and then relaying that information back
to the people relaying it back to the
public so we know what we're in for.
But then money gets involved in those
things and that's what people are
concerned about.
The outcome
and then what you see,
you don't even know if it was the uh,
yeah,
but it also snaps people back and makes
them more involved in growing their own
food and more interested
in organic gardens.
And you've seen a lot of farmers' markets
that are popping up left and right.
I think farmer's markets are amazing.
You go there,
you get a direct connection with
the guy who actually grows the food.
This is the woman who
actually milks these cows.
This is the guy that
actually picks this salary.
He's right there.
This is their,
their special tomatoes.
They have heirloom tomatoes.
You get to meet these people.
You know,
I think that is that that
sort of connection is
exciting to people and that's
the blow back away from
a lot of the other stuff.
But it's all because we're getting
this information and we get to this and
we're,
we're able to make all the
decisions kind of appealing.
Maybe years ago you really
don't want to meet the farmer,
you don't really don't care
where it's tomato came from.
Now it's kind of like more interesting
to understand,
you know,
the,
uh,
the orientation,
you know,
how,
how it's happening or you know,
what's going on.
People are more,
more like the spray on them
that they're the roundup.
And then like I said,
if you know,
people back,
they just,
stuff just happened and
they really weren't,
you know,
uh,
I don't know.
There were certain,
there was just caught up in whatever was
going on because they didn't have a way
of communicating about it.
Like we have to the Internet,
really.
Someone,
yeah,
someone could put up a blog about
here's the dangers of this particular
pesticide on your tomatoes.
And then you hear about that and you go,
wow,
that that is not good and that's real.
The pesticides kill bugs.
Why do they kill bugs?
Cause they're fucking poison.
Why?
Why those plants not getting poisoned?
Well they are,
but just not enough to kill him.
They figured out a way,
make a whole,
it's one
day and I'm in there.
This guy was in there spraying this stuff,
you know,
I said to him,
I said,
hey,
what's this conventional
grown or a organically grown?
What,
what?
What does that mean?
He goes,
well,
he goes,
uh,
I guess if it's organic,
it's done without poison.
And I said,
Huh,
all right.
So the conventional and means,
is that like a with it a,
a poisonous substance in order to,
uh,
okay,
let's find out about that because
I've always wanted to know what is the
official description,
what is the official
definition of organic?
Like I said,
I got this from the clean
up food and I thought,
hey,
he didn't seem to be a scientist.
But that seems to make a lot of sense.
Let's look into Wikipedia.
This is organic foods
are produced using methods
of organic farming.
Currently Baba Baba Baba Baba requires
countries require producers tubes to
obtain special certification or to to
market food as organic within their
borders.
Uh,
the context of these regulations,
organic food is food produced in a way
that complies with organic standards that
keeps saying nothing here.
What's organic there?
Wake up,
back,
hold on.
Janica while the organic standard
is defined differently in different
jurisdictions.
Oh,
okay.
In general,
organic farming response
to site specifics,
farming and crop conditions
by integrating cultural,
biological and mechanical practices
that foster cycling of resources promote
ecological balance and
concern biodiversity.
I didn't know that.
Okay.
Synthetic pesticides and chemical
fertilizers are not allowed,
although certain organically approved
pesticides may be used under limited
conditions in general,
organic foods are not
processed using irradiation,
industrial solvents or
chemical food additives.
I didn't know the first part though.
I didn't know it was defined by a cycling.
Uh,
the conditions cycling of re
resources,
what they need to do,
the nutrients in the soil there.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one of the most difficult things.
Representation I guess is a crop rotation.
And also,
you know,
when you have enormous chunks of land
that are just dedicated entirely to corn
or entirely to this are entirely to that.
You know,
a lot of times those farmlands become
minerally deficient and they have to
actually add minerals to
the ground in order to,
uh,
I think they would use in the old days,
like they would use like fish and stuff
like that to try to replenish their
garden fishes apparently
really good for that.
But uh,
yeah,
the,
the idea that,
that's a weird thing to want
something to be organic.
I think you gotta you gotta ask for that.
It's like,
how did you allow people
to pour poison on,
on food?
How'd you allow people to grow?
I mean,
isn't there another way
to deal with those bugs?
Can you like hire someone to clean the
bugs off and you have to fucking spray
death from the sky?
It sounds ridiculous.
Like my,
my version of it sounds ridiculous.
Birds and animals.
Birds eat all the corn too though,
don't they?
I don't know.
Animals do.
I Dunno.
He'd say,
well,
you know,
I was watching some show the
other day on the history channel.
It was actually about history,
which is hilarious because you
watch the fucking history channel.
When was the last time you
saw some shit about history?
Right?
Never.
It's always like alligator
farmers or something fucked up.
But it was a about locusts.
It was all about,
um,
the early 18 hundreds.
And these people were like a traveling
across the United States setting up farms
and stuff and the locus hit these
people's farms and they had to send in the
army to bring these
people food mean these,
these grasshoppers.
He's locusts were just,
they filled the sky for hours.
Like for hours and hours.
They filled the sky and just flew
by and just destroyed everything.
Just tore through people's crops.
And they were talking about how big,
it must've been the,
the millions and millions of,
of bugs that must've been in the air.
Yeah.
For the corn though,
they went straight for crops.
They just buzz through
and killed everything.
They said you would see it as
a storm cloud coming at you.
And then as you look down or looked up,
rather,
you would realize somewhere along the
line to there wasn't a cloud that was a
storm.
It was cloud.
Right.
Bugs.
Do they make a quickie sound or something?
Pull up,
pull up video of locusts.
Pull up some locust video from the,
you know,
whenever I'm like,
it's got a clicky sound when it's flying.
I don't know.
I never been around locus.
I've been around grasshoppers
and apparently they're in
the grasshopper family.
Yeah.
Where's this locus shallows.
That's so disgusting.
You would just like go outside and you'll
just see this empty shell of what it
looks exactly like a locust.
Oh yeah.
Like the shell of it.
Just the outside of those things.
But if you've,
um,
if you've ever heard of
like biblical predictions,
locus was involved in biblical
predictions of apocalyptic conditions.
You know,
they always talked about
locus locus taking the sky.
Yeah.
Like when you think about
like old horror movies,
you know,
like demonic possession things.
A plague of locusts
hit Egypt this weekend,
causing some citizens to burn
tires and attempt to ward them off.
That's when you know,
shit gets ugly.
30 tires,
burn tires,
swarm of locusts were spotted in several
districts of Cairo on Saturday as they
invaded the Giza area of
the Middle Eastern nations.
Oh,
let's see this shit.
I can't wait.
It's like a previous for a movie.
What is it?
Star Wars Bitch.
30 million and sec.
Once upon a time in a galaxy far,
far away.
Let's see this shit.
I want to see them invade.
I don't say shit or they are,
that's it.
Other comment.
It's not going to be pretty okay.
This is not good film.
This is terrible.
Ah,
yes.
We're not seeing it and good HD.
That's what it is.
We're seeing it in this shitty
youtube thing via our television,
but yeah.
Wow.
That's a lot of God damn bugs.
There's the noise too.
Whoa.
That's so weird.
They like the ultimate gang
and they fly in this huge formation
and just cause massive destruction and
apparently they've done it.
Yeah.
Since the beginning of we occasionally
get together what's in the Bible,
although kiss,
they come in the,
uh,
that's one of the things that
when it signs a gay people,
but
fucking each other.
Whoa,
look at that.
Oh boy.
This isn't the Congo.
I would have said,
Whoa,
look at that.
Oh my God.
Fuck up bitch.
Shut your mouth.
Jesus Christ.
How old is that kid?
She's over eight.
Told her,
shut her whole.
Oh my God,
this kid with the ears shut this kid down.
That's a lot of
that is incredible.
You know what I might be screaming like,
right,
I'll be right there with the kid,
which being on a motorcycle,
just trying to get home and
you're just like spot spot spot.
And this said,
the Congo,
this was in the Congo.
So many of them,
Mommy's not helping you too.
What's she gonna do?
Fucking goddamn storm.
You should be so psyched
that people invented cars.
That's how you should feel right now.
You just feel like people
are awesome cars vented
to protect us from locus.
That's what you should be thinking.
She'd be like,
oh,
that's amazing.
Thank God they invested.
Pesticides are sprayed to the
sky and knock those fuckers dead.
Can they do anything when,
when locusts come do you think?
Can they like throw nets up or anything?
Yeah.
What did they,
how did they stop locusts?
You know,
you do,
you get like a windmill with like a very
large paddle and you just put in the
center of the town.
Just Swat.
Just smack them right in the face as
they come in and just kill them all.
Eventually put a sheet down
below so when you chop them up,
that's a good protein powder there.
It's very good for you.
Right?
It's protein powder.
A lot of people eat bugs and other parts
of the other parts of the world where
they have to and the tasty,
the locust crunchy.
You actually eat them?
Well no,
but what are you saying crash.
Remember these gifts?
It's all gone.
Rock candies.
Yeah.
I never got a chart.
Grasshopper.
So no,
I'd never tried it,
but they used to sell that
shit at urban outfitters.
Actually.
Urban outfitters sells locust.
Yeah.
They said like these weird bugs,
they can just get chocolate and
you answered their chocolate ants,
caterpillars.
The thing about chocolate answers,
you know they,
they're actually good for you.
Like answer actually good for you.
Like if as long as you're not
poisoning ads when you're eating ants,
actually a good source of protein,
so it was a good source of
protein covered in chocolate.
You kind of feel like,
man,
I'm not really eating candy,
but he's still eating candy.
I think we'd put the windmill up
after they hit the corn field.
Then after all full of corn,
then we,
then we make them into the powder and then
they have more nutritional value.
Well,
I think even if you put the windmill up,
you'd only kill the ones
that are near the windmill.
The ones underneath the windmill that
they're like your height and my height.
It's they fly like an inch off the ground.
Those fuckers like they're everywhere.
Kamikazes yeah,
there's so many of them.
There's no room.
They can't all just be in the sky happen.
How do they all get born?
That's a good question.
I think they fuck just to
all of those at one time.
It's like I do,
it's called a cluster fuck.
The biblical cluster.
Fuck,
Huh?
Yeah.
Wow.
We're lucky.
We're very lucky.
Especially here in California.
We don't need to have mosquitoes.
Dude.
You know I thought about
that when I was up in Canada.
We have to,
they have a thing called Thermacell.
You ever heard of a Thermacell?
It's weird.
It's like got a compartment in it that
you put like a a chemical and then you
turn these suckers on and then you put
it down and this like mist comes out and
you can't smell it at all,
but the mosquitoes avoid
you like the plague.
So we would sit down outside in the
woods and it was really mosquito ridden.
Like immediately the mosquitoes
come near and you're like,
Holy Shit,
I don't think I can do this.
Like this is rough.
I,
they were all over the world.
You put this Thermacell thing down,
boom.
10 minutes later they're gone.
Before that I got like a mask on ski mask
and a hat and I got fucking gloves on.
I'm like,
cheese.
And they're trying to
bite me through my glove.
Like you fuckers,
they're everywhere.
Participant in Thermacell,
you keep it on for 10 minutes.
There's no mosquitoes.
Boom.
You know what sucks is those,
uh,
I don't know if they haven't been in Los
Angeles is the Japanese beetles that in
the Midwest we used to get
so many Japanese beetles
that we'd have to have these
bags that you put in your front and back
yard where the beetles will come in and
get collected in there.
You're just like every week you
just have this humongous bag.
Just sweaty bugs.
We were trapping to throw it out.
Yeah.
It's like a beetle.
A hotel.
Yeah.
It's like a beetle traps.
Just bags.
Beatles.
Wow.
I saw some video the other day of
another thing we don't have to deal with.
There was a hailstorm somewhere that it,
fuck this guy's car up.
This guy's entire car was
like covered in like dense,
like hall.
Where as if it had like a really bad
case of chicken pox and script off all of
its scabs.
Like the whole car was just
parked in windows are broken.
They'll list.
The hail was so big.
It's shattered the windshield.
Yeah.
It's one of those hits you in the head.
Your Dad.
Many people die from hail every year.
More than Kelsey.
Lot 10 more than coconuts.
For Real.
Oh,
I don't know.
I know some people,
they say they die from
coconuts and how excited I got.
Well,
yeah,
hundred 50 people die
every year from coconuts.
Really?
Yup.
Okay.
How many people die for a year?
About Hale?
How many would you say if the gas
5,400 die before I left
for California in my house,
got the golf sized hail,
the whole Columbus area
and everybody's car.
It got ruined.
Everybody's house was ruined.
People would moved to Columbus just
to be insurance agents for like a year
because everyone's house,
we're fucked.
And so everyone got new cars.
Like it was so weird that like the whole
city almost got new cars at the same
time.
Oh my God.
There's a hailstorm,
a hailstone in 1928
that weighed 1.5 pounds.
What is it?
How big is that?
It is seven inches.
Wow.
Any weighed 1.5 pounds and
it came from the fucking sky.
It's believed to be the largest
known in the u s at the time,
man,
they captured that bad boy seven inches.
Oh my God.
Okay.
There's another one that in
1970 there was 1.67 pounds,
so it was even bigger.
Jesus Christ,
uh,
Labor Day thunderstorm costs $342 million
worth of insurance damage in Calgary
or out there.
Look,
look it for the bigger one.
Yeah.
Although there's a 12 ounces over there,
you know,
not all the hairs,
the bigger one,
you know,
I was like,
somebody got running around in the a,
there's this ice balls flying around the
block every now and then I can call it
on Kansas had this one in 1992,
two batches of severe
thunderstorms for six hours.
Oh,
within six hours of either
dumped hailstones up to four
and a half inches across
this area,
including the city of Wichita,
surrounding counties of
South Central Kansas.
And over 10,000 homes were damaged.
The hail left wheat fields
in a near total loss.
Property damage totaled $500 million with
crop damage at 100 million and below.
How many people died though?
It can't find it.
Can't find.
Imagine that he'd be the first
dummy that died from Hale.
They stay in when that stuff,
nobody dies.
Not fucking.
You're fine.
You're stuck a wheat.
It doesn't hurt that bad.
Let's see.
Hail Storm.
I tried to get hailstorm,
Fred fatalities.
Let's treat people die.
A year from Hale,
27 people died from tomato,
tornadoes and hailstorms in the Midwest.
What's that says here
at 900 people a year?
Watts.
How many sets from the coconut again?
What'd you say?
One 50 150 shoes.
Where does it say that?
900 a year.
Where's it say that it just came up.
How many people die from
hail and 900 a year?
It can be very dangerous thing.
Are there any instances of death?
There's only one here that says
they know of of the United States.
1939 in Lubbock,
Texas,
a farmer got caught in an open field
and died from a hail last name death.
Fort Collins and infant lying in its
mother's arms was killed by hail in 1979
can you imagine that?
It doesn't seem like
lots and you could do,
man,
if you were caught in an open field
and it started coming down hard,
kills your kid.
Oh,
that's gotta be the,
it's not many people,
man.
I don't believe it's 900 a year.
This actually says the last known death
was caused by hail and the US was in the
year 2000.
That makes sense.
It was 900 total.
Well,
you know what,
today,
people
know so much about storms and if
you live in an area where you might,
you know,
you live in some Kansas type area where
they have hailstorms on a regular basis,
get in.
Yeah,
we'll get the car is getting pummeled.
You know,
hurricanes are waste carrier
hurricanes and the most scary.
Do you ever,
you ever see that show,
this old house you remember?
Yeah,
I remember that guy,
Bob Dylan and uh,
they still have that show on,
I watched it,
uh,
some PBS this weekend and they were
rebuilding the Jersey shore and they were
showing how it's destroyed.
It's destroyed.
But so,
but they've had to do is go under all
these houses and like lift him up all 10
feet.
So all the houses are going up 10
feet to make them taller and taller.
The water comes in again.
They're okay.
Right.
And they have to take
these humongous like,
like,
uh,
like these like call holes,
you know,
they look like a telephone poles and if
they'd like push them into the ground,
like 20 feet or something like that,
I just went on,
I mean,
it's such a pain in the
ass and it's not gonna be,
they say a Jersey shore is probably not
going to come back for another seven to
10 years complete until
it's back to normal.
That's incredible.
I can't believe that
they're going to do that.
Make these polls and then just sit there.
And what if the water's on?
You can imagine fucking sit in your house
and the water comes up to the top of
the pole and you're like,
oh my God,
why don't I build a house here again?
What am I crazy?
Yeah,
I got the ocean on or might have
to put the boat on the roof.
See the ocean like slowly coming up
closer and closer to the bottom of your
house.
You're like,
fuck,
why don't you just go 20 feet?
Why wouldn't you just keep going first?
That's 20 feet.
You get all the way up there and the
shit would be swaying in the breeze.
You'd have to dig deeper
holes for the columns.
You'd have to worry about mean I don't
know how strong the ground is there.
Yeah,
we had a house in Hawaii.
It was on a poles.
It was a Ph.
Dot.
Right at the beach.
It got washed away in 69 wow.
Three houses.
The waves came up so high.
Is it between pipeline and why?
Maybe they live in sunset.
There was,
there's three houses there on poles
cause they'd been washed up on the cam
highway when they brought him back down,
they put them up on these poles
and we lived in one of them.
Wow.
This is pretty cool.
But there's waves never came up that high.
I mean,
I think they were only
counting on tsunamis and shit.
That's what that whole thing,
yeah,
the tsunami.
The thing is if the water comes in,
it's not coming in by itself.
Okay.
Did you ever watch the
tsunami that hit in Japan?
Yes.
It bringing in boats and
houses get hit by a house.
Get,
fuck
your house is going to get hit by a boat.
You don't want that to happen,
man.
You want to get out of there?
Just don't fucking count
on that 10 foot pole.
That fucking,
yeah.
There's people that stayed in,
uh,
you know,
many storms.
I remember Gloria when I was a kid,
when I was a kid and I lived in Boston
is when the Hurricane Gloria hit.
I want to say,
boy,
if I had to guess,
I'd have to say I was in high school,
so I'd say it was in the 80s,
but uh,
it was a huge one and it hit way
the fuck up the east coast and uh,
it put knocked the power
out and a lot of places.
Okay.
Um,
do,
it was 1985,
so it was when I was,
uh,
in high school and I was graduating.
That wasn't like the,
my senior year of high school was 85,
and that's when this fucker hit and it
hit the first major storm to affect New
York and long island directly
since Hurricane Donna in 1960.
So people went a long time.
They went 25 years when they
hadn't had a hurricane hit him.
And this motherfucker came down and
wiped out everything and power was out.
And I lived in Boston,
which is pretty far away from
the epicenter of the storm,
but I remember it being utterly humbling.
I remember we were in my house,
we were looking out the window and
the trees were just fucking like,
they were like,
like leaves.
They were blowing back and forth.
Like they were just leaves.
Like there was no weight to them and he
would see you would go out afterwards
and just trees would
be falling everywhere.
Just collapsed over streets,
collapsed on houses,
collapsing on cars,
just broken trees everywhere.
And just the feeling like,
whoa.
Like,
you know,
I had been in storms before.
I'd been in thunderstorms before.
I'd been in snowstorms before,
but there was something about a
hurricane and even a hurricane that,
you know,
I,
I was way away from the center.
I lived in Boston,
I lived in Newton,
Massachusetts actually.
So that was like,
you know,
a suburb of Boston.
Like,
man,
we didn't,
you know,
we didn't get enough.
Joel was,
yeah,
just the residual.
Incredible.
I mean,
it was,
I couldn't imagine what it would be
like to be in one of those Katrina ones.
The ocean is
so powerful that that water,
which,
you know,
when I was out there,
I started to learn how to surf two
about the same time and near death.
I don't know how many times
you hit by one of these waves.
The water possesses so much power.
You really have to have a respect for it,
you know?
And once it gets riled
up like that coming at,
yeah,
there's not a whole lot going
to be done to slow it down,
I don't think.
Well,
I think we're basing our ideas
about what the atmosphere is like,
like what the weather's like,
what the,
you know,
the safety of being around volcanoes,
the safety of being around the ocean.
We're basing it on the few hundred years.
If people have been paying
attention and taking notes.
You know,
how many people have
been here before that?
The native Americans only.
Really what happened to them.
Yeah.
Well that was us.
Most of it,
but the tsunami.
But there was certainly people
that died in that way as well.
You know,
we just didn't hear about it.
I mean,
they had to be people.
If people have lived in
North America for the past,
you know,
x amount of thousands of years,
like they have evidence that goes way
back to 10,000 years ago of people living
in North America.
So that's the case for sure.
Something during that time,
like there had been a bunch of events,
a bunch of things happening,
we just were not aware.
So when something like Katrina comes or
something like Gloria comes when I was
in high school,
like you,
you go,
wait,
is this po?
This,
this can happen to like,
this can fucking happen.
Like shouldn't we be prepared for this?
How often does this happen?
Well,
the last time it happens,
1960s I just relaxed.
Okay.
But it can happen,
right?
This can happen.
You should prepare for this now
that you know that this can happen,
there should be no houses that are built
from here on out that can't deal with
this because it might not happen,
but it could fucking happen.
It has happened and you
got to have them on record.
You've got one from 1960
you got one from 1985 dot.
What the fuck do I have to tell you?
We're waiting for that.
These pitches are happening.
They're coming.
Let's get ready.
You don't know what can happen.
You can get three of them in a year,
like the ones that existed before.
People measured things.
They still existed.
The giant fucking storms that killed
people before meteorologists were invented
were still valid and this idea that
we're basing it off on this tiny little
window that we've been
alive and I've fucking,
I've been in La since 94 I haven't seen
a single fucking significant earthquake.
There's not worry if
everybody's supposedly,
are you crazy?
This fucking things on a
piece of moving ground.
This is,
you don't live long enough for it to move
that much because the perspective that
you're looking at in terms
of a human life perspective,
you've got to look at it in a fractal
sense like earth and there's no
guarantees.
Yeah.
This years is nothing.
It could be right now
it's time could be up.
We'll just think about what
we were talking about before.
The difference between us
and the people in the 1940s,
the difference between the people in
1940s in the difference between them and
the people in the 1820s add
all that stuff up together,
look at it,
and just go back a few times like that.
A few generations like that.
And that's what we have.
That's the amount of information we have.
And in that time,
in those time periods,
we have a bunch of them.
We have the earthquake
and fire in San Francisco,
we have floods,
we have Hurricane Katrina,
we have glory.
We have the most recent ones.
The,
the tornadoes that the
one that fucking town in.
Um,
what was the town that Joplin,
Mississippi like almost
completely wiped off the map.
I believe it was Joplin.
I should probably put her here.
Mississippi,
Missouri.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Joplin,
Missouri was favorite places.
Hang out in Joplin.
Tornado.
They,
he's joking.
He's joking,
Bro.
Yeah.
In 2011 and Joplin,
a tornado struck Joplin,
Missouri.
Uh,
it was a large,
a larger late May tornado outbreak and
it reached a maximum width ready for this
of one mile.
A width of a mile.
A Tornado.
That's a why?
No,
no,
no.
That's the devastation path.
Oh,
a mile wide when it comes
through the terrorists of five,
I don't know.
What's the FBI in that classification?
I don't know what that means.
I just know it means death.
Uh,
yeah.
Like a reach a maximum width of nearly
one mile during its path through the
southern part of the city.
It rapidly intensified and tracked
eastward through across the city and then
continued eastward across interstate 44
into rural sections of Jasper County and
Newton County.
It,
the third tornado destroyed
Joplin's since May of 1971,
the tornado killed 158 people with
the additional four indirect deaths,
injured some 1000,
150 others and caused damages
amounted to two point $8 billion.
It was the deadliest tornado to strike
the United States since the 1947
tornadoes.
Whoa.
Since the turn it in a
47 there was multiple.
Yeah.
There was the glacier,
the glacier Higgins,
Woodward tornadoes in 1947 sure.
Yeah.
And these,
uh,
they traveled 125 miles from Texas to
Oklahoma destroying everything in its path
because it was originally thought
to have left a 220 mile path,
but it's now believed to have been
a part of a family of eight or nine
tornadoes.
Ooh.
Oh,
fucking family of tornadoes.
These tornadoes,
although deadly,
did not match the astounding
death toll of the earlier event.
Nor did they match the record
speed of that tornado or the,
although at over 40 miles per hour,
they qualified as a fast tracking storm.
Wow.
Mom,
I'm home,
dude.
Could you fucking imagine looking out
your window and seeing nine tornadoes
coming at you and just thinking about
all the times you jerked off and what the
Bible told you and you're
like thinking it was you.
You know,
if you lived in 1947 very low
cost are coming on top of it,
they know it's over.
If you were in Texas and it was 1947
you could convince yourself that those
tornadoes we're coming for
you because you jerked off.
If you were 16 if you were some kid
who's just resisting church so bad,
but you couldn't,
you couldn't stop beating off
and you still go to church,
dad would scream at you and you're in
there beaten off and you look out the
window and you see nine tornadoes headed
your thing and you're fucking convinced
it was you convinced it was
you that killed everybody.
Fire and Brimstone Brian
Red Band masturbate and the
devil is sent his edge men
to take you out of the path and out of
the path of righteousness and you have to
become a priest because everyone
in the town died cause he you,
you and your beating off you
fuck family or tornadoes.
Yeah,
that's a terrifying idea.
There's a lot of heavy vibes on
that man and you know you're behind.
It's a mile wide tornado.
What the hell,
man?
Nine of them now a little patch.
I wonder if I'm accurate.
Tornadoes.
I'm wonder if I'm correct saying the
mile of destruction because it sounded so
much better than just the
actual width of the storm.
So happy we don't have to
deal with tornadoes man.
That shit was so I saw one the other day.
I saw one the other day where
I saw a tornado of leaves.
Oh yeah,
out of nowhere.
Yeah.
Weirdest shit ever.
I mean it wasn't 22 the kills obviously
I was driving and I stopped my car to
watch it.
Yeah.
Crazy.
You ever gone through like the desert?
Like it like,
like driving to like Vegas or something
and you'll just see on the side of the
road like a sand tornado.
You're like,
what the fuck is that?
Is that going to hurt me?
Yeah.
Right.
Like,
um,
they can get them.
I mean they have gotten them
in California before we,
we looked that up one.
What is a tornado
anyway?
Some sort of a weather condition.
Something that,
whether it stops and
it starts to spinning.
I believe it's like cold
weather mixing was warm weather.
Yeah.
Cold France.
Warm,
warm weather is,
it's a spin just,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Okay,
well let's look it up.
Let's talk about what causes
the tornado is a tornado.
This is clone to learn today.
What we're learning every day.
Hopefully.
Well,
I'm not going to go along with that.
I'm still holding the cards.
You are.
It's more sexy black helicopters.
A tornado is a violently rotating column
of air that is in contact with both the
surface of the earth.
N A.
Okay.
Ready for this one.
Woo.
How do you say this?
Cute.
C,
U M U L O n I m.
B u s cubed come.
You'll lawn m bus come Yulana mum bus com.
Kuma cumulonimbus cloud Ku Mula Nimbus
Coombe you low Nimbus cloud or in rare
cases a a the base of a cumulus cloud.
They're often come cumulus and they
were often referred to as twisters are
cyclones,
although the word cyclone is using
meteorology in a wider sense to name any
close low pressure circulation.
Tornadoes come in many shapes and sizes,
but they're typically in the form of a
visible condensation funnel who's narrow
and touches the earth in its often
encircled by a cloud of debris and dust.
Have you ever seen the video from Dallas,
Texas from two years ago where
semis were flying through the air?
Maybe twister,
pull that up.
Pull up semis flying
through the air in Dallas.
Twister.
It was the curb.
Craziest shit.
I was watching it on TV.
I was in Texas at the time too.
I was in another part of Texas and the,
Oh,
wait a minute.
That's not true.
Okay.
No,
it was in Texas during another one,
but it wasn't this one,
the one where they had it on the news.
I think I was in another state,
but I could've been in Texas.
I was like,
I was on the road and I was like,
I could have been in Texas right now.
I've been to Texas.
Anyway,
point being I'm watching
the news and here it is.
This is exactly the footage
and there's a Twitter,
so twist her.
This is on the fucking news and the
guy's talking and you see actual
cool
semi like tractor trailers
flying through the fucking air,
like paper cups,
man.
Like as you're seeing this,
this funnel spinning,
look at that.
See that?
Ah,
those are tractor trailers,
man.
And look,
they get are we log in,
look at it.
You see the things crackles.
You only electrical
fires cause there were,
they're removing them.
They're removing electrical cables and
shit from the ground and shorting things
out.
And eventually it picks up these tractor
trailers and is they're flying through
the fucking air.
Okay.
Is this the same video?
I believe it is.
Okay there.
There's one flying
through the fucking air.
Look at that.
That's attracted
trailer bro.
It's flying.
I mean what does it,
what does that way,
what does it,
but it's got away a few thousand pounds.
Well it depends if it's
got anything in it too.
Well yeah,
but if it does,
even if it doesn't have anything in it,
because there's one,
yeah,
that's flying through the
air and landing on shit.
Boom.
It's throwing it through the air.
Those are all like cargo
boxes and tractor trailers.
It's crazy.
Look at all those tractor trailers.
She's jacked,
picked up and tossed and twisted
around like like an aluminum foil.
Amazing.
The landed near the
highway is fucking crazy.
Mother Nature's the pitch doesn't play.
It's on her terms.
Yeah,
it is on our terms,
especially when we're fucking around
light and shit on fire and sending rocket
ships in the space.
Fucking with the air airplanes burn and
few and Carter burning few and add into
the pollution.
Yeah,
it's weird.
But even if we didn't,
even if we didn't add,
even if we did in the places
that God damn horrifying mess,
even if we didn't do a goddamn thing,
if we lived our lives
completely egocentric,
with organic farming,
if we lived our lives in a completely
harmonious way with nature,
we could still get smushed by
big Robert Space clobbered.
Boom.
Yeah.
Not to say that we shouldn't be,
you know,
loving to our mother earth
and we absolutely should.
Absolutely.
100% without a doubt.
No argument from me,
but it's possible for us to get
fucked up by a super volcano.
Even if we did,
even if we did an ice age can come,
even if we did the best we could do.
Well the dinosaurs are all die
where they hit it with a media.
No,
they were using their
cell phones too much.
Shoot myself itself,
the fucking cell phone,
uh,
drew in magic.
They found old cell phones that
dinosaurs used and we realize we're super
fucking smart but had cell phones.
I picture that guy on that line and uh,
he was in the beginning of a movie and
he was walking by with a phone on his ear
is in front of man's theater.
What was that movie?
There was a,
a,
a last clip they found off of an
old movie Charlie Chaplin Movie.
Oh No,
no,
no.
He had everyone thought,
wow,
that guy walking by with a thing.
Yeah.
It's not what it was.
There was an invention that they had
come up with for people that were hard of
hearing before they had hearing
aids and you hold it up to a year.
It would magnify the sound.
That's what it was.
And so to,
in a blurry image when
you're looking at it,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like a future guys.
It's on a cell phone.
You know,
to this day,
people have ear problems and they,
they get hearing aids.
I see him a lot.
They stick out of their ear.
Well,
back in those days,
they just held it up to their ear.
Right,
right.
So that was a sound.
A
sound amplifier.
Yeah.
If someone's going to do time travel,
I don't think they would go
to the Charlie Chaplin days.
Yeah.
Are they going to hang around
here and do that for you?
Imagine if we did find out that some
dude's been fucking traveling back in time
from the future and we
get up to the future.
One day we meet him,
you're like,
wait a minute,
Dick,
I've seen you before you out.
He's Jimmy Hendricks.
He's fucking,
he's been a bunch of different people.
You know,
like he's just been going back in
time and be in a bad mother fucker.
But really it's just
some guy from the future.
You never know.
You know?
No,
you do know.
That's ridiculous.
And I'm stoned.
Dare you.
Don't,
you never know.
You're hoping Hendrick shows back
up all their city Hendricks here.
Listen,
it was already here.
I love,
I've got to Hendrick shirt on,
man.
It's got a poster here.
That's a cat that left there.
Something behind that,
which is awesome.
He doesn't need to come back.
Oh yeah,
he did his time.
Yeah.
Now you got Gary Clark Jr and I'm not
saying Gary Clark Jr is equivalent to
Hendricks,
but I'm saying,
look,
there's always going to be honey honey.
There's always going to be,
you know,
new bands that come out.
There's always going to be like,
cool,
let's go.
Sounds is a black keys.
There's always going to be,
you know,
there's always cool shit,
man.
It's always coming out.
I'm glad.
Fuck yeah.
This is the best time ever.
I agree.
This is the best time ever on earth.
It's silly for not taking
advantage of the situation.
Then here's what we have.
We're here,
all this stuff to Cape,
keep us happy and keep us occupied.
Calculator watches,
you know,
uh,
cell phones,
they tons of,
uh,
you know,
things that occupy our time.
There are,
there are things that occupy
our time in a negative way.
They can,
they can take your time away,
but they also give you the
opportunity to do things.
It's up to you to decide
what you do with your time.
Exactly.
That's that thing again.
So they said,
oh,
it's bad to be selfish.
And I think,
oh,
it's not,
because if you're conservative
yourself and what you're up to,
your,
you turned out to be a better product
for the other people around you and say,
Oh wow,
this guy's actually spent
some time with himself.
Yeah.
It's a weird word though,
because when I think of southwest,
I think of like,
you know,
like greedy,
like Yo,
you know,
those movies where like people are trapped
somewhere and it turns out one dude's
been hogging all the
food and lying about it.
That's kind of selfish.
Fuck.
That's the way they present.
Right.
So,
you know what I mean?
You hear about that guy,
he like you dick or one
guy like shuts the door.
You know,
like,
stop,
don't shut the door.
He runs away.
That Guy Selfish,
right?
That's a selfish person.
And then you hear the people get killed
by the monster and then you find out
that he shut the door
and you look you dick.
That's a selfish guy.
Um,
but there's also self aware and self
awareness and concentrating on yourself.
And some people are uncomfortable with
other people concentrating on their
shelves.
Some people are,
uh,
they're uncomfortable with people that
are like really into their bodies.
They're uncomfortable with people that
are really into fitness or people that
are really into health.
They get,
they get upset at them,
they don't like it.
It makes them feel bad.
Whenever these,
to look at the label in the store and
you're looking at these people in a
shopping store and they're looking
at the label and what are they?
What do they,
was it,
these are words,
you don't even know what they mean in the,
you know,
many years ago now everybody knows.
Everybody's now looking at it,
high fructose corn syrup.
Look at that.
Times have changed.
You know how many times an
ingredient and La fucking know.
I can't say it.
I'm not going to eat it.
You know,
I can't even read what this stuff is.
I'm not going to put it in my mouth.
I mean what are you kidding?
You know what I started looking at
recently that I never looked at before?
Grams of sugar in drinks,
like grams of sugar and like,
like a a sports drink.
One of those sports drinks type things.
It's crazy.
So it's like more sugar than
he's supposed to have in a day.
Is it sugar?
Even now,
the sensor from the beats and
there's this stuff from the corns.
Yeah,
beet sugar.
You know the sugar.
Yeah.
It's sounds good.
Well that's good.
I think that they're supposed to
have been modified or something.
I don't know.
Once again,
chem trails.
Yeah.
I tried not to get too
upset by all of this,
but try to like when you buy the sugar,
get the cane sugar organic cane,
is it?
That's what the labels,
now that I understand that,
I know labels body doesn't
want sugar like that.
I mean,
you can have it in cookies and you can
have it in cakes and you can have it in
moderation and you'll be fine,
but your body doesn't want it like that.
Your body wants sugar
that's attached to foods.
There's a lot of yummy stuff.
That stuff I love.
Oranges didn't exist.
Okay.
If they didn't exist and
he had to go to some plays,
crazy exotic location,
find an orange,
like a real good ripe Florida orange
when it was big plump ones with it's easy
to peel and he piped into
that as fuck and you're like,
oh,
it's so delicious.
It would be an extreme luxury.
It's so much better than caviar.
It's just caviars hard to get.
But caviar tastes like dog shit.
It's grow.
It's an acquired taste.
No one needs an acquired taste
for oranges are delicious.
You like caviar,
you're one of those motherfuckers.
I used to live with them
Russian people and I got a,
you acquired the taste.
I did acquire the taste,
but uh,
it is,
I can appreciate the,
uh,
nothing wrong with it.
But my point is the old
orange is right there.
Perfect.
Delicious.
Different.
I get it.
It's a sophisticated
palate that represents,
is recognize the subtleties of all caviar.
Caviar is from a very
particular type of sturgeon.
I can't even tell if it's greed.
I mean if it's black or
the red or whatever is a,
it's all tastes kind of like
the same dummy stock shit.
It's like wine.
I never used to.
I know like I can't really
tell the difference.
Oh this tastes like a wine,
you know,
he's good one like wanting to taste good.
I just don't,
it's a good to a Somalia
that is a real job.
Like someone who actually understands
why I let the guys who are really good at
it,
they really,
it really is an art.
It's weird out and stuff.
They don't even swallow it this.
Otherwise they'd get fucked up if they
could tell what it is by swirling and or
somehow in their mouth they,
yeah,
well that you still get drunk but you
get drunk less quick than if you drink it
all,
you know,
it tastes good and your tongue,
and again,
some of them drink it though.
They just go old school and get that
fucking Orson Welles potbelly and keep
rocking it and can keep it in Sonoma
hard every year fucking pound that.
That's Santa Ynez wine.
Yeah.
I never gone on one of those.
Um,
those wine tasting points.
Yes,
exactly.
Brian's,
it's great.
It's fun.
I don't want to be around a bunch of
stinky drunks pretending to be cultured
wherein you fucking boat shoes.
Get away from me dudes with those
moccasins,
with the fucking,
those weird yellow shoe
laces in their moccasins.
Get out of here man.
I know he jokes and yeah,
exactly.
Those weird things.
I know what you're doing.
Get asked to do gigs down
there at the Gainey winery.
Gainey want you heard of that?
Gigs?
Abandoned it shows.
Yeah.
Gainey winery.
They have gigs at a winery.
Yeah.
Outside.
It was to be fun.
Like a party or we're running out of time.
So,
um,
let's talk about,
uh,
your,
your tank center and the new place
that you guys are doing and what's the
difference between what
you're doing and what the,
a lot of these commercial places
that are using these home tanks?
We have a,
there's a real problem with that,
right?
As far as like infections and far as
safety and as far as like everything needs
to be moved to a higher standard.
That's a certainly our
opinion of the situation.
You know,
we,
we've been working with,
you know,
like with the NSF and the other state
and local authorities tend to uh,
get in tune with what's required as
far as rules and regulations as far as
testing the water.
And that's our certification.
We've been certified for that.
Whichever three log kill what they call,
which said 99.9 of all the microorganisms
that are in fact they in fact the
water.
Then they see how long it takes
to eradicate this infection.
And obviously this is a big difference
between someone who just has one that's
only for them,
only for their own personal use,
which is like a lot of these more low
end ones and someone who is running a
commercial business sort of like the
difference between your home pool and your
swimming pool.
I always like to say,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
opening a restaurant
with an easy bake oven,
you know,
it isn't appropriate for appropriate.
This is not up to us to decide anyway.
All is we've had to do is adhere to these
standards and codes that have been set
up by realistic people that that
understand and you've helped with these,
the setting up the standards and codes.
So losing a very important thing for you.
Right?
Super important.
It's more important to us than
anything else is this disinfection,
this ability to disinfect this w the
solution correctly between usages because
we don't use chemicals
and we're all tested,
you know,
to do this three log,
we actually did a seven log in a vessel.
The vessel itself generally
contaminates the specimen,
but we have such a small body of water
in such an intense system there of
cleaning that uh,
they tested the material in the vessel
and we still got the three log and then
surpass that.
But that's within one cleaning cycle
without any of the use of chemicals.
The problem with chemicals now,
which is what everybody else has to
do due to the fact that they don't or
unwilling to spend the money
on the disinfection process,
which is this I told you about this UV
lights like nine grand if 7,500 for the
generators.
And so it's a lot of
bread to get it right man.
You know,
and the electrical stuff,
see our UL listing as well.
Underwriters Laboratory,
this is electricity and people,
you're in a water and electricity,
you can't,
you know,
Eh,
scooter McGee said it's okay
or shifty Williams over here.
Who are these
people?
Where would it makes them
under looking shifty,
fucking shift.
He's got us before,
you know,
I mean we've heard his story,
but the facts are the facts.
You need to go into a laboratory and
evaluate the situation correctly.
We utilizing,
uh,
you know,
methods of that are there ethical,
not,
not
pouring this,
uh,
chemicals,
the chlorine and bromine and or whatever
it is you're pointing as a breaking
down.
Now this,
this material and then creating
a biproduct is biproduct.
Then you know,
you're getting in there with it and
you're sweating or pissing or spinning or
whatever and then you're
mixing you with this,
you know,
the ammonia nitrogen
more of an issue with,
when I talked to him about the tank,
they always say that like,
I'm going to get in the water
that someone else has been in
fucking weird.
It should have an issue with it.
There is an issue with it.
It is like,
you know,
if these things are not
dealt with properly,
they're there,
you know,
it's an infestation
and as the popularity these things grows,
this is something we really need to
consider because this is something that
could become an issue for some folks.
And I know that you're very
conscientious about this.
This is very important to you and this
is like one of the main focuses of
conversation that we've
had over the years,
is about this,
this need to make sure that everything
is like at the same standards of the
tanks that you have.
It's important for the people that
are doing this to have a product,
then that is a credible that
has been designed correctly,
that's had a lot of time
and effort spent to uh,
to verify how it actually
works and what it does and now,
and then,
uh,
does all the harm,
all the good and none of the harm.
Right.
And it's all the potential harm out,
all checked out and
know and documented and,
and,
and then like I said,
this is new one UL stuff too.
The amount of,
you know,
adjustments that we've had to do with
the electrical aspects of these thing are
tremendous,
you know,
but it,
by the time we're all,
we've been working with them,
whatnot,
four years with NSF to try to,
uh,
established these guidelines then for,
you know,
uh,
effective,
purification.
Yes,
too for people then to do this.
Because if you don't have it and
people come away from it with a bad,
you know,
how long is it going to last?
The industry,
you know,
it,
it needs to have guidelines and standards
set up to adhere to then to become a
credible,
you know,
industry.
Well,
I commend the fact also that you're,
you're,
you're meeting it head on
before it becomes a big issue.
Like there's not a lot of people that
are reporting like infections and lot a
lot of people that have
become sick because of it.
But if this industry continues to grow,
the potential instances of people not
taking care of the water can rise and that
could potentially damage there.
The reputation that you fought so hard
to try to let people know about the
positive benefits of this.
Me,
I know you,
you've been working on
this for a long time,
man.
It's catching on now,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's been something I've
been dedicated to with,
you know,
all of my,
everything I have,
you know,
it's been involved in trying to get right.
Cause it's,
it's important,
you know,
that,
uh,
that this technology is
not overlooked right now.
We need to get ahold.
You seen if it,
if it's set up with these little
Mickey mouse second rate rigs,
the authorities are not going to,
okay.
They're not going to allow it.
We've already been,
but they allow it right now.
Now it's unregulated.
Okay,
so it's going to eventually be regular.
So low.
That's what this,
we showed you this,
right?
Well I know,
but people that are listening,
when is this all going to take place?
It's happening now.
We were on,
we have a task group that's been formed
with both the Canadian Ministry of
Health and several health and safety
officials here in this country.
Statewise local ys and NSF national
sanitization foundation to set up these
guidelines.
So they're realizing that this industry
growing and they're stepping in.
Absolutely.
We were at a,
uh,
a a task group.
What was that thing called?
The,
we went to a thing and they
had callers calling in.
It was the most asked about subject,
a topic that they had
conversated about at this,
it was called a task.
What was the meeting call?
Do you think that it's possible for you
to make two different tanks to make a
commercial fully sanitize unit and make
a unit for the home that's less complex
and more affordable?
We see what you were thinking about that
because naturally that would be a good
business sense.
But we got back to the point again,
it's like in order to do it right,
this is what it costs.
I mean,
we could make it Mickey mouse or whatever,
but is it Mickey mouse for the consumer?
Like say if it's just you a
quick crash lives by himself,
crashed,
loves to do the isolation tank,
not gonna jerk off or penis tank.
Or if I do,
I'll be in there with myself.
I,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
he's right.
But if you're going into some place
and it's these people in those,
it's not,
you know,
and then what's happening then
what we were doing was trying to,
you know,
people,
they're cheap,
so they're gonna,
oh,
I'll buy it while people are broke to
fucking super expensive to buy one of
those.
That's correct.
I know that the equipment is really
costly and it's really high end,
but all I'm trying to say is with
our last five minutes of time,
before we turn into a Pumpkin,
all I'm trying to say is,
is it possible that it's,
it could be made into a consumer unit.
Yes,
it would be.
But back to the liability in order to
get this right and not harm anybody,
buy this con,
you know,
different things.
It's,
it's,
it's not easy.
Like he's telling you
how much more do you have
to say about this stuff?
Do you want to do another hour when
to shut this off and do another hour?
You know,
do you cool to talk about this
or are you running out of gas?
I'm not running out of gas.
I don't run out of gas.
Okay.
Let's just wrap this up because this is,
we're running out of time,
so we'll wrap this up.
We'll be right back in
about 10 more minutes.
So I have nine minutes.
I was giving you an extra,
an extra five minutes.
We'll wrap it up.
We'll wrap it up and
we'll come right back.
All right.
Um,
so,
uh,
thanks to uh,
on at.com go to o,
n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
I just want to give us,
give you a chance to go into a lot of
these issues that we talked about before.
So we'll be right back with crash.
It probably won't be a full podcast,
but it'll probably be like 40 minutes.
That's what I recommend.
I recommend another 40 minutes.
I'll be right back.